a new batch of documents related to the
Epstein case have been released this is
the second Trove and oh boy we got some
juicy stuff in here A bunch of A-list
celebrities were named but of course it
doesn't mean that anything wrong it just
means that Epstein liked to walk around
claiming he was friends with a lot of
celebrities but uh you know maybe we
should take a looking at who these
people are cuz it's been known for a
long time what Epstein was doing but the
big story is that a according to one of
the emails in the documents Bill Clinton
went to Vanity Fair and demanded they
not report on what Epstein was doing
with his trafficking if you know what I
mean and so this appears to be an
accusation a report a claim be very
careful here that Bill Clinton was
trying to cover up what Epstein had been
doing questions are why so far it's only
speculation but oh boy we better talk
about that one we got some political
news as well uh the other day there was
was WID there was reporting of
widespread bomb threats at numerous
state capital buildings sparking
evacuations for the second day in a row
this is happened it's happened again
many more evacuations things are getting
crazy out there and then of course
political news according to Newsweek Joe
Biden's volunteers are quitting in
droves they're abandoning the campaign
this is going to get real crazy and I'm
hoping it gets crazy in the sense that
it becomes so overwhelmingly positive
towards Trump that there's not even a
question of political at all and
everyone's like yeah Trump wins and
everybody wants him to but we will see
what happens my friends before we get
started head over to
timcast.net
the Iowa caucus January 15th buyer
tickets now members only now we launched
uh we're doing a town hall with v
ramaswami on the 10th very very
difficult to do to pull all this off but
we're going to do it and uh it's
expensive but we're going to do it and
we sold out those tickets instantly I'm
not kidding there's not not not that
many tickets there're all gone right
when we posted it uh this time we're
posting only for members you got to be a
member if you want to buy the tickets
they're a bit more expensive they're 150
bucks but the Iowa caucus IRL show is
going to be longer it's going to be an
extended show where you're hanging out
and we are absolutely going to be taking
questions from people in the audience so
this is more like directly engage and
interact with the show we have a
multitude of guests that are going to be
joining us not just VI there's it's a
caucus so everyone is going to be there
we've got we've got an uh uh I don't
even know who we're going to have but a
lot of really great people of course
Sheamus and Luke will be joining us and
uh it's going to be a lot of fun so
become a member as a member you can then
also uh get access to the tickets but
you'll also get access to our uncensored
members only show which is coming up
tonight and I will address for those
last night that are wondering what
happened to the show uh it is not just
YouTube's rules but there is there are
rules that every single social media
platform even X has that if the rules
are broken the show is gone we talked
about exactly what happened when we
moved to the uncensored show and
whenever a show gets taken down here on
YouTube or any other platform for that
reason we we will move to the uncensored
members only on
timcast.net if the show is off it's
because usually what happens is
something was said and uh you know show
gets pulled but it will be on
timcast.net
for everybody so uh become a member if
you want to support our work also go to
cast brew.com by castr coffee we sponsor
ourselves it's uh the best coffee you'll
ever have and uh buy it if if you want
to support our work smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show uh with your friends and uh uh
yeah do all that joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is Mona
Salama hey what's going on everybody uh
who are you what do you do all right so
I used to be a reporter I'm analyst
right now I took a time off so I'm
trying to get back into everything but
yeah that's why I'm a reporter truth
Seeker true tell right on you've had a
lot of experience with uh politics to
say the least yeah okay covering you
know you know what you call the Tea
Party um NK um movement covering the
Trump campaign covering Trump presidency
covering 2020 and then everything went
downhill from there cuz you know the new
America hopefully it's going up uphill
from here is that what we want to happen
going uphill sounds hard uphill sounds
exhausting I don't want to go uphill I
want to be on top of the hill already
going downhill well it's you got to go
back up some point but anyway when
things come up things go down should be
fun thanks for H out Hannah CL hey I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
cnr.com that's scanner news uh Hey I
want to say thank you guys for following
at timcast news on Twitter we just hit
100,000 followers today so we're really
excited about that couldn't do it
without your support and I'm very
excited because Brett's here tonight
what is going on guys yes my name is
Brett dvic I am the host of Pop Culture
crisis Monday through Friday 3 p p.m.
Eastern Time right here on YouTube so I
saw somebody talking about like when New
Year's came and they mentioned they're
like wow I hope we have a really really
uneventful 2024 I said and election year
yeah yeah let's uh let's no it's not
going to happen off to a rough start a
rough start 4 days in and here's what we
got here's we're going to do we're going
to we're I'm we're going to do it
everybody check out pop culture crisis
on YouTube right now you want you want
to show this uh Serge we got it right
here pop culture crisis 991,00
subscribers y'all go subscribe to pop
culture crisis because the show format
is very similar except when you Super
Chat On Pop Culture crisis money guns
fire $20 bills into the air and it's
really funny when it lands and the
guests drink or hits them in the face
but uh as you can see Pop Culture crisis
talks about uh pop culture issues so it
it absolutely does it overlaps it
overlaps like we uh like we're going to
be talking about celebrities in
Epstein's Island tonight and all of
these things there's like I mean you you
end up talking you talked about Star
Wars the other day like these topics
Disney all of these things are very very
relevant to the culture we get into it a
lot about whether these things actually
matter because a lot of conservatives
are of this opinion that pop culture
doesn't matter well you know your your
kids are information from somewhere and
they're pushing these ideologies on the
Next Generation somewhere and you have
to be aware of what's actually going on
if you want to fight back against this
what time are you guys live 3 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time so this this is
the point of Pop Culture crisis not
everybody cares about the headline of
this of this video is Epstein list right
you you know a bunch of people who are
going to be like oh I don't care about
that but when you get a new song that
comes out a new movie or a new show most
people are like oh I want to know about
that and these are the people when they
when these shows come out it's these
personalities that are influencing the
younger generation so that's why pop
culture crisis exists hosted by Brett
and Mary Morgan so go subscribe and
let's crack 100,000 subscribers and get
that silver play button also we got
Serge hanging out yes indeed uh you
should check out pop culture chrisis I
should be on there eventually in the
future I know that I haven't been lately
when you got the time when you've got
the time my friend one of these days
will happen again I'm surge.com let's
get into this episode Tim from The Daily
Beast of all sources Bill Clinton
pressured Vanity Fair not to write about
Epstein new docs claim an email from the
newly unsealed court documents reports
quote B Clinton walked into VF and
threatened them not to write about
Epstein's sex trafficking yo uh we
actually have this the Calvin kulage
project tweets out the email it says uh
good points all of them I'm looking at
both sides of the picture on the upside
I will give exposure to build up
publicity for the case etc etc we'll
skip over and then it goes uh goes down
to say uh let me find this point it must
be carefully written and not give any
Notions about the upcoming book for any
new info when I was doing some research
into vity Fair yesterday it does concern
me that they could want to write about
me considering that be Clinton walked
into Vanity Fair and threatened them not
to write about sex trafficking articles
and his good friend Jeffrey Epstein
should I be asking what is this story uh
their writing pertaining to I just thank
goodness for having a friend like you on
the inside who knows how to deal with
the viciousness of today's world there's
another email it says I would let vity
Fair buy your picture viab Brad the big
gamble would be to let him also give the
statement saying your interviews with us
were accurately reported and you have no
more to say this time about how you were
trafficked to PA and other men including
two of the world's most respected
politicians redacted and redacted as
well as women the scenes with gain
because you are writing a book PA of
course prince Andrew and the the other
crazy thing is in the documents
yesterday there was a statement from w a
witness about who they had been
trafficked to and one of those names was
still redacted and the question is why
why why so you of course had prince
Andrew you had Jean Luke Brunell and
then there was a name that was redacted
and everybody wants to know what was
that one name who do you think it was if
you had to put money on it Bill Clinton
yeah I feel like Bill Clinton is the
most obvious but you know the fact the
fact is that it could be a lot of people
which is even more disturbing I I
disagree I I agree and disagree okay it
could be a lot of people Fair okay
that's that's obvious who knows right
but how is it that Jean Luke brunell's
name is released prince Andrew how is it
that a document release that's supposed
to have these names unredacted for
public interest one name still gets
redacted maybe they weren't informed
that they've been subjected to being
that they were called out by the
witnesses no that wouldn't matter there
there actually is a fairly easy and
obvious reason that would something that
would supersede a civil claim so you
have these documents m journalists file
a lawsuit saying Freedom of Information
release the names the court says yes and
reds one name why National
Security what could supersede a lawsuit
on Freedom of Information that would
result in the documents being released
keeping one of those names covered up
national security reasons and that
person still in office billin no no not
still in office the the the if if if
that comes out we know Clinton's named
in these documents but he's not named as
actually having done anything related to
trafficking just having been flying on
the plane and been around these people
and Jeffrey abon said Clinton likes them
young and now we're learning from the
latest document dump that Clinton uh
allegedly went to vity fair and tried to
cover up the Epstein
story was this email oh let's let's pull
let's pull it out it's probably like uh
what do we have uh 2011 okay okay I mean
none of this is surprising at all who
remembers when Amy robach got caught on
the hot mic talking about how she had
the story about Epstein and that the her
producer killed it said she couldn't
wasn't allowed to do it right that was
what 20 2015 or something like that yeah
there was a I mean there was a long time
where epine was being covered up this is
post one of his sex offender convictions
though right like there was a time when
everyone knew that epine had history he
had been convicted in Florida and yet we
still weren't willing to talk about him
it's a very strange time some people
think it's Joe Biden that's this is my
like current theory that actually Joe
Biden is is going to be on the list I
know we were floating Hunter earlier
before the show but uh I think Joe Biden
is sort of a more precarious variable it
can't be because he was too long yeah
it's too long it's too long no no that's
it Brett Nails it take Hillary Clinton
can it be Hillary Clint Hillary Clinton
no uh it's not long enough so uh take a
look at the length of the black bar but
that's not what matters because when
you're doing redactions the the the the
placement of the redaction could be it's
it's it's someone clicks it and drags it
we don't know we don't know like the
same size as prince Andrew that name but
right so you look at the commas of where
it's placed in the document because the
spacing of the text is not altered and
then what you can do is you can go from
comma to comma and you can actually
determine how many characters exist in
this person's name you don't know it
could be three in their first name and
seven in the last name or seven in their
first name three in their last name who
knows but it looks like it's about the
length of probably not John Luke beral
that's too long maybe though maybe
though prince Andrew Bill Richardson
seems to to to fit uh rather well in
that spacing we we know it's not I'm not
saying it's literally Bill Richardson
I'm saying a name of that size yeah
those many characters so uh it doesn't
seem like it would be Bill Clinton no
dtz is named outright in these documents
so you don't need to redact that and his
name's longer yeah uh I don't think
Clinton because if it said Bill Clinton
you can tell it would be shorter so not
Bill Clinton and it won't be Hillary
right Hillary I mean that what what you
never know she could be part of it like
m the m but these are guys right that's
I'm saying this is me like not looking
at the emails and just like depending on
it I mean yeah you what I really want
you know why I'm not really like
depending on the on the documents cuz a
lot of this is like heate I really just
really want to see the the JP Morgan
list and see who he paid off cuz that's
where you find out where the real crimes
were hidden damn maybe that's where
Stephen Hawking is maybe that's his name
right there do you think that's enough
letter I was very sad that I didn't get
to talk about the Stephen Hawkings stuff
last night Colin rug tweeted this
yesterday he said a single name is red
in a list of individuals who gain
Maxwell allegedly directed underage
girls to have sex with who is this
person the redacted name was next to
former New Mex Mexico Governor Bill
Richardson billionaire hedge fund
manager Glenn duin uh prince Andrew
model Scout Jean Luke Brunell and
computer scientist Marvin Minsky
released the name I think it's a
national security thing prince Andrew is
not a national security issue for the
United States right I'm willing to bet
it could be someone who's currently
still in office but then you're saying
like um is National Security that means
it has to be somebody current because
you Bill Clinton is over there like it's
to be
current like like Clinton for former
president still have Secret Service yeah
and so they could they could argue that
like information retained by the
president could you like I mean they'd
say this like if a former president was
directly implicated in these documents
the National Security implications for
this country would be nuts treaties
could be at risk border disputes could
ignite anything Bill Clinton had done
could start to unravel it could cause
problems in the stock market so
absolutely you could say Jimmy Carter
for all we know and they're going to be
like no way but I don't think it say bin
I think the redaction bar is too long
the spacing is too wide says Joseph
Biden Joseph R Biden yeah but it would
uh it's it's r r Biden isn't it no what
what it what he has more than one M name
doesn't he it's robertina something like
that I think it's just Joseph Robert
Biden Joseph R Biden really it's even
worse if the fact that they're serving
president gets to keep them off the list
for and then using National Security as
a crappy
excuse I in this day age and oh you're
right yeah Joseph Robinette Biden Jr oh
yeah the junior so then I don't think
they'd use his middle his middle name
though and I think Joseph R Biden would
be too long yeah too and then he has
he's popularly known as Joe I think the
same way that they're listing you know
that's why they did hypothetically
prince Andrew has a last name too
there's no reason to say Joe Biden
people are only saying Joe Biden because
he's a president right now right and
well one thing I can tell you we know
it's not Donald Trump for a fact could
it be Barack
Obama yeah Barack Obama may fit because
think about it this is
2011 well Obama was serving as president
in 2011 this this document is actually
not this is 2016 yeah it's oh it's a
2016 so said everything could been
unraveled and why is this reacted now
though uh I don't think Barack Obama no
no I have this weird thing I think
Barack Obama's into other things I don't
think I don't think this is kind of his
Jam is and this is I mean I can't flush
this the out totally right now I have to
do some research but prince Andrew Bill
Richardson they're actually closer in
age from what I understand Barack
Obama's slightly younger than them so
there is sort of a a similar age group
of people that means they were running
in similar circles Barack in some ways
was sort of outside that and I think he
has different
proclivities I can't speculate on his
proclivities partially because my mind
I'm half joking actually and I'm sure
like the chat is just igniting over what
that means about Barack you got my mind
thinking like guy at the bar him and the
guy at the bar yeah I'm just thinking
about National Security and I'm just
think who worked in Obama's
administration that's now working in um
tons of them the thing Obama That's is
heavily staffed by former you got my
mind but it's not it doesn't need to be
a president it can it it be it could be
a like a dude named like John Jackson
his name is redacted because he worked
for the CIA but like if you could think
of like what's his name um Secretary of
State um damn it just um
blinking National Security it does say
on the next line another Prince like
there's prince Andrew johnell Bill
richardon another Prince which one
somebody named this Prince w Really
another Prince the petty little one or
the one that does know what British wait
wait that that's actually a really good
point nobody pointed out says other than
Glen du uh glin Glen Dubin redacted
prince Andrew John Luke Bernell Bill
Richardson another Prince the large
Hotel chain owner and Marvin Minsky is
there anyone
else what do you mean another
Prince ask who that yeah that's my
breaking news journalism who because the
thing is second Prince and it doesn't
have to I mean like the the queen of
Denmark just announced kind of abruptly
on New Year's Day or Eve that she was
going to going to resign so there's this
moment where I'm like is it someone in
the Danish monarchy cuz there are
princes there like her her son the
prince is about to become king like I
I'm not here to slander him I'm just
saying hypothetically we're thinking
British Monarchy but there are tons of
princes out there how come nobody and
nobody's not famous like the two
brothers I I didn't even realize the
princesses nobody cares about royalty
the way I do but no that's true that's
but but I like the Queens who's the
large Hotel chain owner I mean that's
also interesting right like what's his
name Cass mates cuz he's a really um
John caes cuz he umarket in and he
donated to a lot of Republicans and
Democrats he's he's what a billionaire
based out New York his daughter's like
the the chair of the New York Manhattan
Republicans I just think I'm like look
look look Colin Colin rug tweeted this
and he's like who's the redacted name
and I'm like who is this other
prince now we got this Prince yeah but
then maybe if we knew who the redacted
name was we might also know who the
other prince was right what if it said
like an and an artist formerly known as
Prince that's what I said as as long as
it's not it's long that it can't be that
as long as Minnesota is safe I leave
Minnesota out of this I don't want any
besmirchment to his
name okay check it out uh someone
actually did the work they said using
Courier new the redaction is 16
characters
long now everyone's going to be sitting
here this is the best cross puzzle ever
I know right I was like can we just play
tetas now
yeah interesting now people will have to
start uh looking at politicians and
getting characters uh character limits
on all of their names so they can start
putting them in there to see who it ends
up being to I I I think it's important
to point out however letter across it's
it's the name has 15 characters because
there's a space between the first second
and last name uh there's one there's one
uh Source reporting or one publication
in The Messengers reporting that one of
the victims said she had sex with Hyatt
hotel's billionaire Tom pritzker I
thought it was pritzker I thought that
might be priter so that's probably wait
the brother the the brother of um
Chicago um Chicago Governor I mean not
Chicago Illinois governor I doubt they
related but yeah he's they're related I
mean no I don't know they but that
family is real EST real EST um and then
that brings in Obama because again ill
got it nailed the guys close the G you
heard it here first ladies and gentlem
his sister worked in Obama
Administration um all right here's what
we're going to do we've got the power of
45,000 people right now ladies and
gentlemen a name with 15 characters okay
so it's it's 16 total characters but we
assume there's a space there cuz I doubt
whoever they're naming goes like a
single name because usually single names
are small like Bono but uh we've got so
so someone who's got a name with 15
characters and I know between the 45,000
people someone can figure it out or at
least make some good guesses so uh
crowdsourcing good luck crowd sourcing
prominent high-profile individual here
here's what we're thinking someone who
has the ability to get a foyer request
released redacted still this potentially
could be one of the Doe's that has
requested so let's take a look at who
are the remaining people that have got
to stay on their names being released it
could be the name was not released
because they've got an appeal but then
we're going to know which doe John do or
Jane do it is who's getting that delay
is it possible that they're rejecting
the name because that person is
cooperating with whatever investigation
but is investigation kind of mostly over
I
don't never this is not an investigation
this is a civil lawsuit for defamation
it never actually went anywhere it was
settled out of court the documents get
released and now people are speculating
as to the criminal elements that may
have may be involved in this so my my
first speculation is is I would say this
in in starting the investigation the
Assumption I would make is something
related to National Security allowing
the name to remain redacted so
overthinking uh law enforcement
politics uh you know like law
enforcement intelligence agencies uh it
it could be however also related to
those who requested a a an extension on
having their name remain redacted
so this is here's the important thing
the people who said that uh uh there's
the Jane do 107 saying don't release my
name CU I live in a conservative country
and it'll be bad news for
me these are accusations of child
trafficking yeah who would get who could
get their name redacted and prince
Andrew couldn't prince Andrew could not
get his name withheld from this but this
person could but didn't his family um
excommunicate him sure sure but still
say before all this happened they
excommunicated him that's why they were
to release his name like that am I wrong
in thinking that he already faced a
lawsuit in in England about it so in
some ways like his connection to
this establish someone else allegation
you were right about the pritzkers by
the way JB prisk related to the Hyatt
Family yeah the only reason I knew about
that is when um that Harvard thing and
then apparently the sister is in the
board yeah and I was like when I started
like trying to like find out who's
connected to who a lot of them are like
Democratic donors and RV Weinstein fits
people are pointing that but I why would
he be redacted exactly he would not be
of all the people he's the least likely
to be redacted so I'm that's why I'm
thinking like but I'm loving former FBI
CIA guys
that worked in the Clinton
Administration Obama administration even
Bush Administration bush had a bunch of
Democrats so I mean theoretically that
would be military then right there are a
couple different military like secret or
heads of military organizations that
have carried over through several
administrations yeah but no I was just
thinking about it like think of like the
guys who worked in the CIA worked in the
heads of the CIA FBI to be like National
Security let's jump to the next portion
of this story I love this headline from
Fox News Jeffrey Epstein documents name
A-list celebrities hate this a little
clickbait breaking news breaking news
just a little bit just a little bit
because it is factually true and it's
relatively vague but I got to be honest
I don't know how you would actually
title this story while trying to provide
the context that they're not potentially
wrongdoers TMZ just listed like the name
like names and then just said no
wrongdoing it just listed in the in the
headline that there was no wrongdoing
found and then then the cron underneath
it was like they had no wrongdoing it's
just all no they put it right in the
headline like right in the main headline
on the website it listed it almost like
a lot of people would say depending on
what your opinion on the media is like
oh they're just covering up for them
because my favorite thing to always
point out is like whenever they talk
about Epstein like there's like several
documentaries on Epstein they're all on
like Hulu and all these things and they
all have pictures of him and Trump on
there because the media hates Trump and
they want to Tar him with DMZ is like
these people are bread and butter you
cannot dispers their good name we need
them to create our beautiful content I
mean the fox story is is I agree with
Tim it can be really hard a headline
because like you're trying to get it out
quickly you you know a long headline is
is wordy on the other hand it was
annoying screwing scre screw oh oh my
gosh scrolling through this article
because they'd be like ah yes somebody
asked if you would ever met George Lucas
from Star Wars and she was like No And
so that's the mention or something
exactly exactly only I'm just shocked
about this whole thing is that there's
no Bank Executives named but so like
Wall Street is like clean from all this
so it's only like you know no no I mean
this is just who they asked about in the
deposition say there's not one single
this is not this is these are not the
Epstein client FS no no I know that but
I'm just saying like I mean that
obviously would be part of it well known
like Wall Street Executives that's I'm I
would say these documents don't get
anywhere near the majority of the
clients that we want to see exposed
because this is this was part of a
defamation lawsuit a lot of these
documents that are being released are
related to the original investigation
into Epstein that were used as evidence
in the defamation trial that's my
understanding could be wrong I that's
what's being reported we be very very
very careful here because you got a lot
of people's names are getting wrapped up
in for the deposition was Paul Beach who
did the investigation right uh I don't
know was it yeah that's I remember like
Palm Beach did like this thorough
investigation and then that's what only
it didn't lead to any state or federal
charges only led to that civil that's
why was like there's so many missing
pieces to everything going on in this I
love how that okay so let's go through
the list say Naomi Campbell is named
leard DiCaprio Kate Blanchet Bruce
Wilson Cameron Diaz George Lucas Michael
Jackson Kevin spy okay now that last one
all right now the last one okay but the
other I don't know watch did you watch
his thing with Tucker Oh yeah I don't
know what's going on
man the Kevin he ruined House of Cards
it was so good and then the last season
just sucked technically like he didn't
ruin the
show his bad his bad life choices are
what are what ruined the show the show
was so good he's got to win an award for
when he was accused of all this
wrongdoing he should win an award for
his response where they're just like
Kevin spy you've been accused of rape on
several instances and he goes I'm gay I
am a gay man I'm choing to live my life
this way I thought that was incredible
but also he doesn't um he's not
interested in the the flavors that
Epstein seems to be offering right so I
I don't know that this is actually he he
is not a good person necessarily but I
don't know that he's actually uh someone
we'd expect to see on the list at all
there are a lot of people who are
accusing him that have mysteriously died
in the last several years for five have
uh passed away before you know being
able to take him to court but he was
acquitted what now twice in in the UK
and and more but that video with with
Tucker Carlson I was like we were
watching we're like who is this for like
I legitimately can't figure out who it's
for it it almost looks fake like if you
watch the video full screen on a larger
TV it almost doesn't look real and it
feels like this weird like like he he it
almost looks green screen in a way he
green screen Tucker Carlson in or Tucker
Tu yeah like they added him in there and
he do and like he makes great Illusions
to House of Cards in the show when he
talks about uh you know pushing
journalists in a certain direction which
is a very clear push to the end of
season one it was just it was it was
rough but it was it was really weird to
watch cuz I'm like who is he Tucker
Carlson's wearing like acid washed jeans
I'm like is this you trying to say this
is an AI generator video I don't think
it is but like there was just if it was
surely Tucker's team would have spoken
out yeah yeah like I he's wearing acid
wash jeans in there though maybe he's
just like trying to explore his sense of
fashion though but no cuz in the thing
like Kevin Spacey like basically alludes
to he's like I he's like do you ever
watch Netflix anymore he says that to
Spacey goes probably as much as you
watch Fox these days I do want to say uh
I am fascinated that of all the names
that are in there Jimmy Kimmel is not
and but the reason is not because I
think you know I want to outright I'm
not accusing Jim Jimmy Kimmel of doing
anything wrong it's that he was actually
business partners with ep's chef and so
when Aaron Rogers said you know Jimmy
Kimmel must be worried about this and
then Jimmy Kimmel and assume him I was
like well hold on yeah what do you have
to hide it's not that it's said what
Roger said was completely reasonable
this this guy worked with what was the
guy Chef Perry Lang or whatever the
guy's name was he was Epstein's personal
chef and my understanding is there was a
report that said that they were uh
co-owners of a restaurant or that Jimmy
Kimmel was in some way involved there's
videos of them they're friends so if
Jimmy Kimmel appeared in this document I
would not be surprised I'm not I'm not
saying he did anything wrong all these
celebrities that are being named uh 99%
of them there's no accusation of of
wrongdoing they just ask them did you
ever see Bruce Willis there no but the
well and anyone who's named I'm sure
does not actually want their name to
come up in this even if it's completely
anoc nicer to not be involved at all
just look at his reaction like he was
like if you keep mentioning my now I'm
going to sue it was just like why you're
like getting so like jumpy about this
the average P but the thing is though is
we're we're pointing out the fact that
when you read these documents a lot of
these people aren't accused of wrong
doing just putting your name and
Epstein's name next to each other now is
enough to tarnish you so it doesn't
matter if not being accused of
wrongdoing just by being associated with
but the media is going to cover you up
they have trouble but so you feel like
Kimmel's like sphar was somewhat
reasonable I yeah I I think if if you're
not doing anything wrong and your name
comes up in something like this then
it's probably a pretty reasonable
response to be like I don't want to be
attached to this at all and there's no
legal recourse right it's it's not like
you can sue the documents for life like
there's kind of nothing you can do about
it you feel like it's it's like there's
a lot of like ghoulishness to all of
this like people were talking about how
all of these names coming out has been
like album drops for like it's been made
light of so much that it's kind of hard
to when you you have to re you have to
read what's actually happening here to
reacquaint yourself with just how
horrific so much of this stuff is and if
if we were to get a Client List in some
ways would people be like but we already
kind of got this weird list that sort of
meant nothing is in some ways this this
weird drip of information actually
making people less interested in what
was going on and the fact that there
were people you know who potentially
were promoting human trafficking and
using their wealth and status to get get
terrible things so we were talking just
a moment ago about there there's this
you know this list of names and one of
them's redacted we think it's probably a
name with 15 characters including a
space giving a total of 16 characters
and somehow this name got reded I I'm
loving all of these all the speculation
some people are saying like Harvey
Weinstein fits sure but of all the names
to be reded his would be the last cuz
he's he's locked up or I don't know is
he still in jail he's still in jail and
uh but someone just super chatted Steven
colar and I'm just like okay will I
really do appreciate the hatred we have
for the corporate press I I'm I don't
think Steven colar has the National
Security level to keep that redution uh
it's a lot of clout for Steven coar a
lot of clout for stepen coar considering
like billionaires and Millionaires and
even prince Andrew couldn't keep their
names out of it that's why I'm assuming
National Security but uh good guesses
but it's all speculative I mean we we
got no idea I really the best way to do
it would be if you had you know somehow
compiled a list of people who have been
known to have flown on the airplane and
then you go through and you count the
characters cuz otherwise like I could
just shout out names for the rest of
forever and probably NE wouldn't
necessarily get Clos it has to come from
a list of people that were already known
or room which to have ties to Epstein uh
and I don't know necessarily that
Stephen cbear was there's a lot of names
that fit and it's kind of crazy because
the chat's lighten up and they're saying
a bunch of names and I'm like these
names all fit I just wonder at the end
of all these document drops at the end
of it we're just going to come out and
be like what is what at the end what is
this everybody's just going to be
speculating is just anything's ever
going to come out out all this the way
how they're just dropping this like
nothing changes I I I don't think so I I
don't I do not believe that we're in a
period where we can say nothing changes
because everything has changed for the
first time in US history the former
president's been indicted there're it's
not just an indictment I mean they're
they're coming after ways they're trying
to keep them off the keeping him off the
ballot isn't is is is a de it's it's
soft War it is it is shutting down the
election the side that's doing that to
him is the side that's on the list so
they're going to prevent anything from
changing because they're not the ones
that they're people are if now Trump's
name was on the list then yeah sure no
but but this is the point they've never
been threatened before and now these
people on the list are doing things that
have never been done it's changed
something happened in this country that
has put these people in fear for their
for their lives social media and the
generation or or yes perhaps that's what
leads to a Donald Trump election in 2016
they never thought possible and I do
believe there's a strong possibility
that should Donald Trump get elected
yeah the names that get released in this
go to jail I do believe that's possible
I'm not saying it's probable I'm not
saying it's a guarantee I'm saying I
would not be surprised look there's that
clip going viral right now where Donald
Trump was asked about Bill Clinton and
he goes nice guy but he's got a lot of
stuff coming up with that Epstein you
know and everyone's like what did Trump
know about this M so what happens if
Donald Trump look Donald Trump says I
your retribution this guy's pissed
there's a possibility maybe it's 0.1% I
don't know he gets elected and the first
thing he does is he says I want to know
everybody who worked with Epstein and
we're going to lock him all up well he
has to get the FBI guys to do it well I
think part of it is that would be one of
the only ways to restore public trust I
think that if an average America I mean
with everything happened with Hunter
Biden this year and him get his plea
deals and this this very obvious
two-tier justice system I think if Trump
were elected actually seeing someone who
is on eping a known associate who
partook in all of this stuff being sent
to prisent is actually the only way to
get the American people to think maybe
there is a reason to trust people in
power we have a good answer we have a
good answer uh someone said uh this is
um Barrett 13313 it's Alan dtz and the
reason why his name was redacted is
because je fre uh uh recanted her
accusations against them La in
2022 so that could e but you know what I
got to push back on that his name is all
over these documents right all over them
with accusations of raping children so
that being the case I don't think this
one time they redact his name does
William Burns fit he's a no no okay he
was CIA he's CIA right now yeah but he's
like theoretically someone who flew on
one of Epstein's oh interesting so no
that's too short it's too short but look
no even if I'm learning something
amazing there are a lot of people in
government who have 15 character names
cuz people are posting all this stuff
I'm like oh that's actually a really
good point like like there's too many of
them I don't know which one you pick
talking about The Hunt of Biden did you
see the reports from the Democrats from
the Democrat oversight they released a
report talk about like Donald Trump uh
obtained like $7.8 million from foreign
governments because they all stood in
his hotels when he was president so
they're trying to say that was form a
collusion that what the Republicans are
doing an attacking huntter Biden Donald
Trump did as president and nobody's
really talking about it except for like
if you watch it in the MSNBC but they're
trying to really make a dis as now the
biggest deal ever it was um Jamie Raskin
he's doing this it started today but the
because the everything with the EP and
everybody was really into this I
wouldn't be surprised that they're
they're going to try to turn the tables
and use that report against Trump as
another way they're trying to throw
everything to make it stick at him and
they were already doing that when he was
in office though they tried to argue
repeatedly that he was making money off
yeah but no but they now 150 page
someone someone said ask grock this is
Joshua Park ask grock for powerful
people with 50 letter names so I went to
grock and I said give me a list of
politicians who have 15 characters
between their first and last name ladies
and gentlemen this list is damning okay
you ready is this American or forign
Alexander Hamilton Benjamin Franklin
Thomas Jefferson James Madison George
Washington John Adams wait wait hold on
act none of these none of these people
have 15 characters in their names oh so
grock is covering up for Epstein I knew
it I I knew this was corrupt stra to the
top go straight to the top
Free Speech my ass over
there oh that's crazy it's becoming a
foreign concept nowadays I mean I think
part of like first off I feel like this
is the new version of Wordle and I'm
really expecting it to like vibr be like
you got some of the letters right of
rearrange them if uh like they should do
a crossword puzzle in the New York Times
and actually include this in there who
is the I'm sure Bill Clinton said don't
I wouldn't be surprised Bill Clinton has
already marched it it been like do not
dare don't you dare uh that would be so
funny wasn't wasn't there a case where
like they he wanted delegates to stay at
Mara Lago and and host an event there
and they made him not do it uh Trump
during it when he was in office what was
that for do you remember that I don't
remember deals I mean there was also a
report I saw a long time ago that Joe
Biden had personally hosted like
diplomats and his home in Delaware but
then I had a really hard time tracking
that down I think that there are
probably reasons people ask for things
like that but you know it's very easy to
be like no Mr President that is a
violation ever and he's like okay they
can't see my golf course I mean like
there were all kinds of things like
there was a reason that Trump put his
sons in charge of the business and left
off you know what I mean like I think
you did as much as you could to mitigate
potentially having conflict in that case
the thing about Hunter Biden is that the
more that comes out about his case the
more obvious is through his emails and
everything that he was specifically
saying I am the pre the son of an
influential American politician and give
me my money if if if you do what if you
if I get benefits you get benefits and
there's no evidence that anyone in the
Trump organization has done that yeah
but that's what they're try to do
they're try to say like he didn't recuse
himself which he actually did I remember
that press conference right before
during his um the transition and they're
trying to say like he didn't recuse
himself his name was still under the
Trump organization they were trying to
still I mean his name was still Lally
Trump and to a certain extent yes of
course that name gained even more
prominence than it already had but on
the other hand you know as far as I know
and I'm not an expert on his business
dealings it's not like he was like I am
president Trump now a go tell everyone
in Ireland that I'll open a golf course
there and because I'm the president like
it it wasn't that way that's very
different they act like like the Trump
Hotel was created in 2015 it's not like
he was doing this you know for decades
beforehand yeah it's very very strange
but you know I obviously think it's
important to hold politicians their
families accountable I mean this is
what's interesting about um all of the
legislation that that's getting Post in
Congress right now saying we should be
really wary of the stock trades being
made by
politicians gr is so
stupid I I asked it for a list of
politicians with 15 characters and their
names and it gave me a list of just
first it gave me like James I gave you
the first 15 people so then I said give
me a list of politicians alive today and
it gave me a list of random politicians
and I said none of those I wrote none of
those people have 15 letters in their
name and it goes oh I'm sorry that list
didn't uh actually adhere to what you
had asked and then it went I I I said so
make a list with 15 uh letters and uh
let me see if I can pull back up I Clos
it 15 characters right cuz obviously B
in it and and then it said apples
bananas cherries dates elderberries figs
grapes honeydew Iceberg I just put it
I'm like okay this idiot those are like
code names it's on regular mode it's not
on fun mode should we ask uh what's the
other one Gemini chat GPT chat GPT no
let's uh let's jump to this next story
here while uh we discuss the darkness
that is happening in this country we do
have good news it's from newsweek.com
Joe Biden campaign volunteers are
quitting in droves take a look at this
because of what's group of staffers
working on President Joe Biden's
re-election campaign warned the
president that his volunteers are
quitting and droves over his handling of
Israel's military response in the Gaza
Strip Biden has faced immense pressure
from members of his own party over the
US policies in light of the surpriz
homas tech on October 7th you know look
we have uh a lot of people come on the
show are Jewish that may be surprising
to uh for many people who watch to know
well other people think it's too many
people who are Jewish well uh we have
criticized both way I think we have 10
times the national average uh uh Jewish
people je of guests who are Jewish so
it's what someone did a thing is like it
was 21% of our guests are Jewish or
something and I'm like yeah it's
probably because they're abrahamic
conservatives I don't know whatever and
they're prominent social media
personalities or whatever but uh I
literally don't care however we talk to
a lot of these people and it's really
fascinating to hear what they'll say
behind the scenes about their family
members they'll say on the show a lot of
a lot of progressive Jewish individuals
are waking up to what the left is and
what Democrats are doing because of the
the attack on Israel behind the scenes
they'll say the same thing but be a bit
more specific cuz they don't want to put
their families at risk I can respect
that and they'll say like I got I got an
aunt she's liberal and she came freaking
out like what's going on and I'm like I
told you I'm just imagining all of the
Hanukkah dinners where you had these
liberal Jewish people meeting with their
conservative relatives and the conserva
like we told you this was going on and
you didn't believe us and now they do
and now you take a look what's going on
with Joe Biden's campaign this split is
insane Joe Biden is losing staff members
because he won't support Hamas but who
are they they they're not staff members
I mean they might be paid but it's
they're saying volunteers which probably
probably people who are volunteering in
their early 20s mid 20s you maybe up
until early 30s and that group of
progressive liberal people tend to be
very
anti- leftist and so it's interesting
because it's actually a huge age divide
that's what I think the Democratic party
is starting to realize that the older
members basically the Boomer Democrats
have a very different position on this
this International issue than their
younger cohorts so instead of it being
like yes come come take this position
volunteer a third batch may have just
dropped right right now within the past
few minutes that's why you see such an
uh an outsized influence of those of
that discussion on social media now why
when you look at comment sections on
Instagram it's all free Palestine and
and Tik Tok right this is what we heard
reported over and over again that you
know the mainstream media might be
presenting a more pro-israel present
presentation but Tik Tok was
predominantly Pro Palestine it was Jen's
ears do love Osama Bin Laden what a
predicted that on 2023 but it was
actually the media that blew that up
that story cuz like it was only like a
few people who had it was like Tik Tac
it was like only like few million and
then the media talked about it and next
thing you know it blew up to like
billions of views yeah it's a I mean a
few million is still a lot to me yeah I
know say but compared to Tik Tok views
that's like nothing um the uh like right
now you're seeing a a live Fe just we've
had however for many decades of colleges
that have told you that the place that
you were born from is evil and that your
ancestry is evil and all of those things
that your Progressive and leftist
professors have indoctrinated into the
previous generations is finally coming
to pass as the new generation hits all
of these problems in society right now
there's no love of old Americana or what
this country used to be there's no sense
of identity here anymore and all they're
left with is a deep burning hatred for
this country and a lot of allies not
surpris that Joe Biden is losing his
young volunteers and I'm presuming
they're young I haven't read all his I
guarantee you they're they're on the
side the same way that Harvard is losing
its older billionaire donors who are
saying the things that you're teaching
the students the the positions the
students are taking are in congruous
with my views and I no longer want to
support you financially the thing that
young people have to offer any sort of
influential campaign is their time and
their energy it's not the billionaire
donor that's out knocking on doors
although they contribute in a different
way their financial contrib means a lot
to Harvard but political campaigns need
the young people and so I mean I think
it's good right it's not that I like
conflict is that I like this party
having to reckon with itself that it is
saying one thing like it bothers me a
lot that people always like the
Republican part is about to fall apart
it's crazy and in my position you know I
think conservative movements have lots
of different parts that occasionally
make basically become allies at times on
certain issues whereas Democrats tend to
be very lock step you believe these
things but they no longer real iiz that
they are the party that is preaching
things that the older leadership doesn't
believe in it's interesting to see them
fall apart in front of our eyes well we
saw that starting with when AOC got
elected and when a lot of these younger
progressives got elected right that
there was great divides but she kind of
ended up being more of a she fell along
party lines in a lot of issues
eventually the fact that she voted for
the Ukrainian Aid you're supposed to be
a progressive yeah like at least th
Thomas Massie didn't even vote for that
yeah but Massie is really interesting
because he ultimately principled he has
certain things that he believes in and
he will not back down but that's when I
think you lost the progressives right
there the minute they said yes to this
and they said that we're never going to
fund any war no matter how strong their
allies are or how fake our allies are
with them we're not supposed to be
funding this Wars we have to be like we
have to fund Healthcare we have to fund
this and then all of a sudden you
started seeing like they voted no
problems they didn't even like use that
as a bargaining chip like they did with
the bill back better like they were
using that over Nancy Pelosi's had
that's why it was never been able to
pass and then it took a while that like
had to come back and then Joe man got
involved and all that so the fact that
they didn't use that over the NY pel's
head that was really telling about the
progressives so I think now they're
using this to show to like bring back
the power that they once had but then it
comes to the fact that like what is your
principle are you for the war or you're
against the war like what are you
exactly for like it's a lot of I think
you look at a story like
this and this is It's the year has only
just begun and I see two things from
this the first is is yo we are winning
by a lot you know with with the uh uh
the purchase of of X the boycott of
these big companies the organizational
power of the anti-establishment and the
pro constitutional republic uh uh
faction is tremendous and seeing more
and more victories every single day and
then you see that Joe Biden's volunteers
are quitting over an ideological split
the Democrats are fractured they're
falling apart we've already gone through
years of the viral story Democrat quits
party how many times did we see a story
like that remember when they were
calling into CNN being like I am
quitting I will never vote Democrat
again no no this was last like a year no
but say like every time there's a war
going on they always say I'm going to
quit the Democratic party do they really
do and they do and so in the past few
years you had that Viral story where
they were calling in a cpan complaining
about what Joe Biden had been doing Dem
yeah it was crazy and and it goes viral
we get more and more of that now we've
got you know every couple of months
Democrat quits and switches to the
Republican party now Joe Biden can't
even keep volunteers on because they're
far left extremists it's kind of
fascinating if you think about it
because a lot of this is fueled by uh
foreign interference using social media
manipulation and I love how the left
claimed that for so long over Trump but
the reality is it's targeting them they
always project you get these apps that
are advocating for Hamas and then these
young people become Pro Hamas and then
all of a sudden they quit Joe Biden's
campaign creating a
direct like probability of Americans
uniting around actual American values so
if if all of these young people are
being subverted into supporting things
like Hamas but it's not the majority all
that will happen is these people have no
political power America will prevail the
constitutional republic will prevail
Donald Trump will get elected but are
they really like going back are they
really supporting Hamas or they are they
really trying to like support the
Palestinian cause like the Palestinian
people so they are they Hamas Hamas yeah
look a week here talk about all the
people who are like Pro Palestine I am
specifically referring to people who are
pramas why why am I referring to them
because they in New York were marching
around chanting and for Hamas and
calling them
Heroes well okay I get what your point
but I'm say when they had rallies in New
York over you talk about like the
rallies or you talk about people who are
when they had rallies in New York and
and you know several hundred people show
up the speakers at this event would get
up and say the Freedom Fighters fired
5,000 Rockets Landing in Tel Aviv and
they all clap and cheer and scream so
those are pramas protesters in New York
City okay sure if you want to argue that
there is an individual on social media
who not who doesn't like Hamas and
they're Pro Palestine I know many of
them I'm not talking about them you're
you're allowed to be Pro Palestine but
the problem is these most of these
people are calling Hamas Freedom
Fighters okay that's why they're Med m
and the idea is that it it it will
uniquely leech votes from the Democrats
assuming assuming that they don't end up
just following in falling in line when
the next election comes because a lot of
them do right like as much as they hate
it they end up following falling line
vote blue no matter who doesn't really
matter but us at least the hope would be
that they're so ideologically inclined
that for once they won't just end up
voting on party lines because they
actually have a problem with the they
actually do support Hamas but did you
see the recent USA Today poll they said
young voters younger than me younger
than 35 Trump leads by like about two or
three points and that's really shocking
I always I always thought that like you
know between 20 and 30s you're going to
vote blue because you're like so lost
until you start paying taxes then you're
like holy crap I got to vote Republican
because I cannot anymore like the
Democrat Party so you're wondering like
these gen Z's like a lot of them are
crazy but a lot of them are actually
waking up yeah I think they're very
divided is I think that you'll have uh
there'll be an extreme generation where
some people sit very far one end of the
political and ideological spectrum and
some people end up sitting unfortunately
extremely far on the other side and so I
I think that it's it's sort of like when
you talk about the economy you have the
disappearing middle class I think there
is a The Disappearing moderate class of
gen Z and you know the question would be
are they able to reconcile or do they
ultimately meet on the other end of the
political horseshoe and their Norms that
we would view as extreme the things that
they agree on are are out of the box
we're not going to expect them yeah also
be very very first of all be very very
careful of any polls that are conducted
this early in in the election season no
but it's too telling I always think of
it as like a quiz but also like be very
careful because what happens a lot of
time is if they start projecting that
Trump is super far ahead then people get
complacent and they think I don't have
to go out and vote so I'm not going to
so don't lose if you know depending on
what your thoughts on voting are if
you're really really Pro Trump whatever
it is don't allow that to make you
complacent because I do think a lot of
times they end up doing that I mean
theoretically it would I mean I wish I
don't think this the case it would fuel
a sort of down ticket Sprint where
people are saying well I know exactly
who I want to vote for even if he's
ahead who else do I care about who do I
care about on the state level who do I
care about representing me in the senate
in Congress you know who who is my
Governor because you feel like you've
locked up one office that shouldn't be
enough I don't think this is actually
how voters operate I this is my uh my
idealistic worldview that you if you
feel like well I definitely know who's
going to be president you want to send
them into their term with strong support
both in the in Congress and in the
states uh but going we'll see but going
back what you said like you said be
careful but maybe you never know maybe
they're using to say they want to vote
for Trump so they could get rid of Biden
and put somebody like Gavin Newsome a
younger a younger Dem you never know
that could be telling that's why I say I
always think of these polls as quiz and
then like the then when you start going
into the all these votings I think of it
like all the delegates are like the
midterms like the midterm like when you
take a test in college and then to the
general election that's your final
that's how I see it so when people are
like writing off the polls I'm like no
gotta be careful these polls are
doelling also was that a nation was that
done Nationwide was that done no the USA
said it was Nationwide okay I think but
it was telling like um Joe Biden's
losing support by blacks by 25 points
from like 2020 he's losing Hispanics
Trump is leading with Hispanics young
voters and Trump's gaining and all and
he's gaining so like he went like Biden
went from like 80 to
60 but do you think that's people who
would you know part of it is are are
what I'm curious to see is if there's a
a large number of Voters who sit out
this election like what is voter Turner
actually I think the young ones are if
it's going to be Biden so I'm thinking
that's why I say like cuz just because
they're not voting for Biden doesn't
mean that they're gained by Trump yes
remember a lot of people sat out 2016
because they said like I don't like
Trump or Hillary I'm just sitting this
one out but the same thing in 2020 they
they sat out too but I'm saying more
yeah 90 more that's the saying these
polls can be telling as a way of like
trying to push Biden out Donald Trump is
uh in swing States winning amongst
people who did not vote in 2020 by
double digit margin some up to 40%
that's what I'm saying like these polls
could be telling push them out in
Michigan they p people who did not vote
in 2020 and Trump has a 40% lead so he's
like it's like 60 you know 30 or
something and the whole thing going back
at the Hamas War like um be 6020 the the
Israel war like Trump is leading with
the arab-american votes and like the
Republican Party cannot take that for
granted they have to understand both
sides of it it cannot be all 100% pro-
Israel they I think the Republican party
is much more tolerant of different views
I think the Democrats are way way more
out each other's Trump is very um for
both sides but you see look at the
debate stage they're both like the Sansa
between the sanses and Haley they're
both graveling between trying to get
like the Israeli and apack you know
endorsements they're more worried about
that than they're worried about the
American people but that's because
they're so far behind in the polls I
mean it almost doesn't matter what
they're trying to do because ultimately
the popular vote indicates that they
support Trump and Trump is taking a
position that is attempting to be
moderate which also Joe Biden has
attempted to be moderate on the issue
and it's failed because people don't
trust him but I'm saying but like going
if the first time ever this poll has
with Arab American community and Trump
is leading and remember they try to push
that whole Muslim band and they try to
like everything with Trump the fact that
he what the Muslim band what was that
the whole like they were trying to like
the like if you look going back to
Michigan that's a heavily populated area
of Arabs and Trump is leading and and
that's what Dearborn Dearborn but what
what what Muslim band you the Muslim
band they try to push that against like
um they try to p push it they're trying
to the media they remember the first
you're saying the media was lying about
Trump claiming he wanted right right so
that's the one thing when you comes to
Arabs and Muslims that they that's the
one thing they just don't like about
Trump but they love everything about his
economic polies and stuff like that but
when it came to like Israel like even
though he was very Trump was very pro
Israel he did have understanding of
working his first the first country he
visited diplomatic was Saudi Arabia yeah
so Accords yeah yeah and he worked on
that so but the fact that the Republican
party is take it for granted and they're
only picking one side and they're
groeling and then you're saying like
yeah well they're behind the poles look
at like the santis he's like bashing I
just think that Republicans take a third
side which is to say that they don't
really want to have an interventionist
position at all there are a lot of
Republicans they sound like bush in the
the Bas stage they sound like Bush Jr or
Dick Cheney with three inas and lipstick
so it just reminds me like the
Republican party and even like the RNC
like they have no FS given about the
minority and the people the color people
who are choosing to be Republicans cuz
they only want to pick the side that
they're used to the whole establishment
that's what I'm saying we have to be
careful with this like the polls are
telling but Republicans they're very
known for up I always say
that like I mean this is again why I
think it's interesting that there are so
many Republicans right now who you know
theoretically they could be divided they
could say I support this side of that
war I support this side of the war but
there are a fair number of them who are
like the is our Focus has to be domestic
our Focus has to be on what's going home
and I don't really hear a similar echo
in the Democratic party it might be
there and just not might not be as loud
Republicans have a a another position to
take that is not available to democratic
uh politicians right now Democrat
politicians have to pick a side that's
what their voters want whereas if you're
a republican voter and you know maybe
you feel real strongly about one side
maybe feel strongly with the other if
you have a republican saying well
obviously this is a big conflict there's
a lot going on there but my priority is
to secure our B but there is like we
need Israel we need to make sure we need
to eliminate them like this is water of
combat like and then you have the Santa
insulting Arabs which is now you to like
trigger me and like you're losing
people's respect and like he shouldn't
be talking like talk about like Arabs
wearing man dresses I wouldn't be
talking when you're wearing three in
chill boy and you're down the polls by
55 points yeah you're trying to like
catch up with a girl who's like an
Alibaba version of Hillary Clinton do
you think like for minority voters that
are joining the Republican party or who
are likely to support a republican
candidate this time do you think uh they
are looking for candidates who support a
certain side of the war or would they be
would an America First Position first it
has to be America First agenda the only
reason why they want to come to this
country he also does need to bring up
the Abraham Accords a lot like I think a
good amount because you're going to the
people who are voting America First are
going to be all in on your domestic
policy if you're putting you know if
it's talking about closing the border
and and Shoring up things there right
sure but right now with International
conflict being such a big part of the
story uh pushing them to see that there
was a time not that long ago when we did
have a more stable you know world for
yeah like I think but we have the
Republican parties on the stage pushing
to fund a country that has a budget
surplus when we're running a budget
deficit and we can't even keep up we
just hit 34 trilon we just hit 34
trillion yesterday and we're growing
everybody allbody here owes
$105,000 in that for what I didn't pay
for that for college I didn't want that
for my mortgage but I got to pay that
for for some War so is Israel's got a
budget surplus yes what's you know what
it is I mean their budget surplus their
GDP is about 4% a year and we're fund
their military we fund three what 3.8
billion a year they run a budget surplus
in between two Wars right now the
American people for the first time in 35
years as of January of 2023 uh Israel
posts budget surplus driven by higher
tax revenue so what are they looking at
they're like 2.8 uh a budget surplus of
$2.85 billion how much do we give them
3.8 so they actually they're run they
could cover a good portion of that at
this point so but we want to get the 14
billion and like right now we have like
no
money they're like you can pay a little
bit more of taxes can't you you can go
ahead and we're going to have to pay
taxes what saying Trump taxes they're
they're they have no the American
politicians have no problem bleeding us
dry right so they they don't have a
problem problem with that and that's an
issue right now the fact that they want
to TI to the Border they want to tie to
border security and I'm sick and tired
of these Republicans running and
trekking down to the southern border
check your ass back to the capital right
now and get something done the border is
out of control well let's uh let's talk
about this we have a tweet from Elon
Musk he says at this point there is no
question that this Administration is
actively facilitating illegal
immigration the numbers speak for
themselves let me just say that one more
time Elon Musk says Joe Biden is
facilitating illegal immigration let me
one up that for you Elon the Biden
Administration is actively colluding
with human traffickers that's a fact
they've been doing it for years there's
multiple news reports loading children
they're smuggling children they're
trafficking children on planes in uh in
in the dead of night there's videos of
this and you can look at all the
statements from politicians it's been a
story for 5 years now take a look at
this graph by all available metrics this
administration's border policy is a
disaster take a look at this under Trump
there was a major spike in encounters
and we know this because that's when we
got the Caravans Trump went nuts then we
see a massive decline to the lowest
level we've seen in a long time because
Trump said we're going to shut this down
as soon as Joe Biden's elected he opened
the doors just take a look at the
numbers they speak for themselves we
have unprecedented illegal immigration
and right now the Biden Administration
is suing Texas attempting to do
everything in their power to stop the
border states from putting an end to The
Invasion the incursion of 10,000 plus
people per day at the southern border
this is sedition against the United
States it is a VI a direct violation of
the Constitution and I will say this
I've said it several times the only
reason it happens is because there are
people in law enforcement who say to
themselves I know it's wrong but I've
got to feed my kids that is that is the
argument made by every corrupt
individual who exemplifies evil they cut
a deal with the devil to save their
families and I totally understand why
they would because they want to make
sure their kids have full bellies and
they took the deal with the devil
figuratively or L literally however you
want to see it to sell out and destroy
this country for themselves for their
short-term gains the only thing is those
kids will inherit a pile of Embers
because of what they've done yeah I mean
this is a really interesting argument
because if you work for you know Customs
for trol if you're working at a federal
level theoretically Texas is really
trying to do the opposite right Texas is
trying to enforce border law so could
maybe leave your job for a state level
position and still get to work in your
chosen field and also have a governor
who is willing to back you there are
ways that especially with the border
that you don't have to be necessarily
supporting the Biden Administration who
is trying to undermine all immigration
laws that are on the books I just got to
get a little biblical with it and I'll
say this again let's if you are an
atheist by all means you're allowed to
be I'm not a Christian um take this all
as metaphor uh take it figuratively if
you are religious take it literally when
we had the guys from Angel Studios
talking about the film The Shift where
the benefactor transports a guy to a
reality without his family and he says
I'll give you everything back I'll give
you everything you've ever dreamed of
just serve me and instead the man begins
to pray and refuses to serve what is
figuratively the devil and I believe
they said it was it was it was
effectively like the story of job you
know and I'm not it's been a really long
time since I I studied these stories but
no matter how bad things got would never
just give in and and take the assistance
of the of the of the devil so this this
is what I see figuratively literally
however you want to cut it there are
federal law enforcement agents that are
actively working against the local
residents and law enforcement of Texas
to stop them from protecting their homes
and these people are doing it and I
would say full well they know what
they're doing is evil but they're saying
to themselves yeah but if I leave this
job my kids won't have food cuz we hear
it all the time it's true your kids
won't have food so as you are in service
of darkness and evil and cutting that
deal with the devil you know I certainly
understand why you did it not like
anyone's going to forgive you
though no I mean I think especially with
the Border crisis as bad as it is I
wonder if Democrats look at themselves
and say I'm going to vote for Joe Biden
even though that's a vote to continue
human trafficking across the border
right it's a vote to
continue drug traffing that issue they
up until now right they'll say all the
time you know human trafficking is bad
and this is awful and whatever else
except when it's on their door up and
they could theoretically do something
about it I mean I can understand where
if you've been told shutting the Border
makes you racist else why they afraid of
it but that's what they should think of
it as that those are the real world
consequences H you know a lot of
Republicans talk about the the drug
trafficking across the border which is
obviously awful it affects a lot of
Americans the obod crisis is uh you know
just a complete assault on our nation
on the other if that argument won't do
if you don't care what happens to
Americans why don't you care what
happens to young children and women who
are trafficked across the border like at
what point do you recognize that you are
advocating for a international violation
of any kind of human decency and instead
they're like no it's bad we got to keep
the Border open it's great I mean this
is the thing this is my favorite topic
actually talk about with people who are
left leaning because it's like a lot of
people who would vote Democrat are
bleeding hearts right they believe
these polies harm people they are more
likely to be open to them I think the
border is the border is a crazy issue
because there were so many Republicans
who like would not talk about it they
were afraid to be called racist they
afraid to do whatever I mean the
Republican house I think or congress
wouldn't necessarily they they fought
giving Trump funding for the border wall
when he was in office because they were
like well it's not that big of PRI
govern to shut down for that right and
look at us now like this is a major
issue we are paying prices and in fact
we had a president that wanted to
intercede earlier who wanted to stop
this and even if you don't like Trump
right don't you care about human
trafficking don't you care about
Neighbors in your communities dying of
drug overdoses like this is the big
Reckoning at the border which is it was
messaged messaging around it was like if
you want to close it you're racist and
the reality is actually it's a huge it's
a hugely compassionate issue to say we
are not going to have this this uh
Finish Line at which point people are
incentivized to send their families to
people who want to traffic and harm them
but are they getting that message
because you have all these organizations
that are saying like they're screaming
the racism yeah so and they there are a
lot of organizations that are built
around encouraging people to cross like
nonprofit organizations that are uh
structured around encouraging cross the
border right and so why would you turn
off that cash flow if you if the purpose
of your nonprofit is to solve an issue
like trying to get people to cross
illegally puts them out of business if
they solve the problem can you guess how
much the cartel has made in December
alone
with the record breaking of 300,000 2
million a day I'm talking about in a day
a day how much they 32 million dollar a
day from this it's also an issue of
framing like I think this has a lot to
do with the echo chambers that most
people who follow politics find
themselves in so you can frame that
issue in that way and it's accurate but
sharing the horrors of what's going on
is not going to be how they receive that
information they're not going to get the
information from somebody who's willing
to share all the facts of what it
actually means to go through a border
crossing right not the coyotes not all
of the drugs that come through it's
Being Framed to them whether it's by
MSNBC CNN any of these places as a
humanitarian issue that they have to be
a bleeding hard on so therefore they
don't get the full breath of what's
actually happening which is why their
viws don't
change I I I got an idea I got a I got a
really really great idea uh when these
people come to the border and they
demand Asylum what we do is we get them
a very comfortable bus really nice one
like I'm talking like you ever see those
luxury buses that go from like New York
to DC and they got recliner chairs you
know about the Greyhound they're not
Greyhounds are not comfortable but they
got these really nice ones it's like
super cheap and then they got these big
chairs up top and you got this glass SE
oh this is really great you can see
everything we'll take all yeah we'll put
all the migrants on there and we'll
bring them to Native American
reservations and then when the left you
know advocates for immigration we'll say
absolutely yeah we'll send them to the
Native American reservations isn't that
what's what's wrong why are you why are
you upset about aren't they like
federally protected
sure so here's the solution the the
reservations are federally protected
federally recognized Texas is upset
about doesn't want people there here's a
solution the left thinks migration is a
good thing so who would complain if we
send these immigrants to Native American
reservations everyone should be happy
right that's true well this idiot mayor
of M well former idiot mayor of Min
because I don't live in New York City
anymore he's suing the Texas bus company
so I'm me how much damage is that going
to do I I think I think the answer here
is just for Abbott to send the the
migrant to Native American reservations
and then ask the left why they're upset
if they get mad about it they should be
very happy CU migration is a good thing
right mhm if you like it so much why
don't you encourage it everywhere it's
it's weird right I mean this we know
what'll happen the left will call him
racist and start attacking him because
it's that's what they're doing if the
migrants come to this country it's a
good thing but you know that if a
governor sent them to a Native American
reservation they'd say how dare you
you're racist blah blah blah I mean look
how fast they cleared out Martha's
Vineyard right oh man
there are not we we don't like migrants
going to certain places L the liberal
Banshee shrieking over the Martha's
Vineyard thing was hilarious the most
NIMBY of nimi that there is but they're
more you are yes no I think it's crazy I
mean the other part that bothers me
about this is like where were you guys
back in the day I love that Republicans
have gotten on board I will be a little
bit cynical right now and say this has
been an issue that anyone could have
spotted for a long time and I just don't
understand why people didn't embrace it
sooner I can never understand that and
it was also something that at least back
in the early 2010s and and earlier that
Democrats at least paid lip service to
right they pretended to want to close
the border Clinton in one of Cate of was
like let's close the border it's
important Obama mention Obama had like
the most support CH here in any
Democratic presidency in the last 30
years deporter and chief right so it's
not completely look at his immigration
rate that's like this is like Biden's
biggest accomplishment it's not that
economy or not the stock market that
like you know recuperated all 2022
losses it's the fact that he's broken
the the migration encounters every
single month and he even decreased the
one month because of title 42 oh he
should get like a Guinness World Record
shouldn't he I know right for for least
secure border under presidency Joe Biden
and you broke every single record even
broke in Bush's record and that was not
really hard to do people who are like
good more this is a great idea I mean I
think the fact that they could just walk
in and there's no like you know
background check there's nothing going
on like had their press conference the
other day there were migrants crossing
in the background and that's not even
the first time that has happened where
there's been a live press confence need
to stop with this like lip service and
like pull the strings like stop with
this like Shenanigans and make it happen
in capital but that's what they were
doing with like when they had that
Ukraine funding bill and they were like
okay if you want to pass this you have
to increase border security and
Democrats were like crazy absolutely not
now we don't support Ukraine also we
haven't talked to about Ukraine in a
while I feel like uh it's just throwback
who I just find it funny like the
Senators that are really trying to get
the push the uh immigration in the
Ukraine have the only one is like Cinema
and she's only doing this because of
election year for her then you got a guy
from like what Chris where you got
um Connecticut and then you got um
Langford from
Oklahoma and like they really just
really mostly push it for Ukraine fund M
there's nothing really about anything
for the Border cuz they really not
really talking about it no I mean the
border is something Republicans alone
talk about which is crazy they'll talk
about it but they want to attach to
something can we stop attaching things
to things well right now they're using
it as a tool to stop other things right
because they know Democrats won't give
it on it they the Democrats see
supporting a closed border or even you
know enforcing book laws that are on the
books how dare we as a death as as as
the uh you know end of their career so
Republicans are using it to stop things
and I think you're right they should do
things to move it forward unfortunately
I think they believe that the Biden
Administration would veto or stop
anything no because you why they're
going to Cave the same way how they did
with the whole death um the dep ceiling
we caved and we added more to the
deficit than we did to try to like you
know cut down and
redu I mean it's possible the thing is
Republicans are all lip talk and they
all bark they're like little
Chihuahuas and they think they're like
pit bulls and it's just like all right
stop with this lip service and what chip
Roy said is true there's nothing we
could take back home and say that we
accomplish anything cuz we have't it
let's uh let's jump to this story this
is big from NBC News state government
buildings face bomb threats for a second
consecutive day buildings across
Mississippi and Arkansas received bomb
threats on Thursday one day after
similar threats for state capital
complexes across the US to evacuate so
uh yesterday it was eight states nine
nine states yeah allans over what all
Republicans it's a mix and it's not all
like swing so what's going on do you
tell Santa clir oh well okay so as you
guys know this is one of my favorite
stories right now so yesterday the
capital buildings in I'm going to read
from my list Connecticut Georgia
Kentucky Mississippi Montana Maine
Minnesota and oh Michigan Hawai and
Hawaii all received bomb threats they
were all evacuated most of them were in
the morning based on local time main was
like afternoon uh some of them were in
session having come back from the winter
holiday some of them weren't so they all
uh had these sweeps the majority of the
ones that I could track down the the law
enfor M that were releasing information
said there were hoaxes were receive via
email email typically it seemed like it
went to someone who worked at the state
government building and it triggered an
evacuation today there are other
government buildings in multiple the
states so like Mississippi has several
not the state capital but other
Affiliated government buildings that are
receiving similar threats the
interesting one from yesterday was that
Maine had received I think it was 60
schools in Maine mid December had
received bomb threats via email so this
is something that's going on uh you know
it's not exactly the same thing but it's
very much like a swatting for these
government buildings in some cases and
you're asking about patterns so some are
Republican states some are are Democrats
some are in session some are not in
session it's not really like there's a
consistent pattern from what I can see
but it is interesting that now it's
spreading throughout other St states
that were already affected are seeing
other and you're saying swatting I mean
they're bomb threats so they're not
sending in the SWAT team necessarily but
they are disrup business remember when
Target faced a bunch of these these
threats I wonder if this is related I
wonder if whoever did in the casinos
right casinos it reminds me of the when
the casinos had am I wrong in
remembering the story they receed some
like not bomb threat but it was like you
know we've hijacked all your data please
pay us and no that's way different
that's way the hotel my only point is
it's interesting because it's all cyber
crime like no none of the buildings that
were affected yesterday and as far as I
know I haven't done all of my due
diligence research on the buildings that
were affected today none of them
actually had explosives in them so
you're saying this is cyber crime
because they just found out like Russia
has been hijacking our cyber security
for the past 13 months this these were
emails that were sent that's no that's
what I'm trying to see say all of it is
done online it doesn't know there's no
clear indication it's not like four
people walked into buildings you
know all emails it theoretically could
all be one person or it's a coordinated
cyber Le attack I mean you just don't
know and some of it is it's foreign
testing the response from these capitals
I think it's foreign I think it's an act
of War uh I I should say that's the that
seems the most probable outcome because
it is it is crippling our our ability to
govern it's shutting down our
institutions we have the weakest cyber
security system we have out there and we
pretend we do we have the strongest we
have the weakest the fact that they
hijacked the Congress website they did
it like last year in two seconds and
they the reality is there's there's no
defense no one has any defense anywhere
in the world defense is hard offense is
super easy when it comes to cyber
warfare there's uh it just there's no
way to defend a system it's just not
possible there are certain things you
can do but man I love how all of these
uh you know every business will have
like their cyber security policy you
know I worked at Vice they have this
they're like everybody just do not click
links in your emails and the next day
it's like oh we got TW you know 12 more
people click the links we got fished
again passwords got it's oh non-stop no
matter how many times you tell the
person not to do something they'll do it
anyway and then they'll lie about it and
say they didn't do it or like or they'll
like click on the email for the Nigerian
prince because they think they're going
to be a billionaire you know what the
the the mo the most basic way people
breach systems is back in the day it
used to be that the quote unquote hacker
would drop a floppy disc in front of a
bank and then what happens is someone
will pick it up walk inside stick it in
the computer and go what's this computer
infected then it became CDs then it
became USBS and USBS are the are the
commonplace thing now someone will just
they'll put a virus on a USB they'll
walk in front of the building Target
building and they'll just drop it and
they all all they got to do is wait cuz
sooner or later someone walking into
that that building for their job will
see the USB and pick it up and stick it
right in their computer on the network
and infect the network and no matter
what you do no matter how many times you
tell these people they don't care
because that guy who works in the mail
room goes I know we're not supposed to
but what do I care clicks it in and goes
oh crap it was a virus wasn't me and
throw a stick away nothing you can do
about it nothing so these kind of
vulnerabilities we face look if if they
can shut down state capitals and what
are we what are we dealing with like 13
states in two days how many states is
this it's definitely nine stat capitals
today some of them are happening in the
same place so let's say there if there
are two I only saw two new affected
states that would be like 10 or 11 but
still evacuating our state capital
buildings inhibiting our ability to
convene and govern imagine if they do
that and they will when an actual attack
happens right and then all of a sudden
our uh uh centers of Power are unable to
coordinate and figure out what's going
on I get asked this all the time people
are like how could a civil war really
happen oh my it's just so insane how how
how easy it is to break a machine I can
give you a million different scenarios
but imagine what would happen if there
was a terror attack and then at the same
time the foreign adversary who did it
shuts down Communications in the United
States what happens when multiple law
enforcement agencies show up to the same
scene unable to communicate how many
stories have there been where police
show up on scene and shoot the wrong guy
mhm in New York they open fire on a
perpetrator and they h a bunch of
innocent people on accident it is chaos
and if they can't coordinate communicate
and there's an explosion in DC and then
one jurisdiction says we we we've lost
Communications we got to figure out
what's going on and there's there's no
way to communicate effectively then a
bunch of random people show up and no
one knows who anybody is yeah now I I do
think the the our security opar in the
United States has plans for things like
this I'm just saying you bring this on
the federal level not the state but I'm
talking about DC you bring this to the
to the border of Texas and then it's
chaos for the feds respond there's an
attack The Border's in chaos people are
running and screaming state law
enforcement shows up you got some plane
closed guys nobody knows who's who
there's a story going viral it's just
dropped about uh Trump that that Trump
supporter who got arrested by the feds
what's what's his name actually I don't
know if it pulled up it was the guy who
ran that Trump group in Georgia or
whatever and two plane closed guys
branish a firearm at him and he runs and
then he tries to flee from him and turns
out they were FBI agents and everyone's
saying they they did it in this way
because they wanted him to get shot and
killed to fight back not realizing they
were law enforcement plane Clos FBI show
up to an attack with guns drawn state
law enforcement doesn't know who these
guys are they show up and they say drop
your guns and they're all screaming at
each other you ever see that video of
the ATF guy getting detained by the cops
every libertarian loves this video it's
the meme it's when that got turned into
the meme he walked to the guy's house
because the guy reportedly bought a
shotgun and he's like you know give me
give me your information banging on the
door the guy who lives there calls the
Poli there a strange man with a gun is
banging on my door the cops you up and
they're like on the ground now and he
goes no I'm I'm law enforcement they're
like shut your mouth on the ground now
and the and the ATF guy is like no I
don't have to and then they throw him
down he's screaming oh I can't breathe I
can't breathe have like a cold word for
each other or I just watched so much
Blue Bloods no I don't know I'm just
saying watch the video they throw this
ATF the ground they P him down he's
screaming you can't breathe they don't
care yeah they don't care now this was
one ATF guy and a handful of cops so it
gets resolved afterwards but imagine if
this is federal law enforcement
subverting the law on the border Texas
state level trying to enforce the law on
the border an attack happens
Communications go down it's serious man
it's like that mean it say like uh cops
arrest undercover cops for drug that
happens all the time all the time and is
it is it it has happened on several
occasions been documented your tax
dollars at work the FBI is setting up a
fake drug sell and then the DEA is doing
a fake drug buy and then they all turn
out to be like oh oh we're all law
enforcement you the taxpayer paid for
all of it you got to ask yourself why
why is this happening this
week I mean I think it's start of the
New Year what's your theory I'm just
saying like it's just TR to like ploy to
show how like the capitals are just
being I I think this day something
happens maybe I mean one of the things
that I found interesting about this is
not like they picked the swing States
and then every they picked a bunch of
State houses of various sizes not all of
our most populated states across the
country and not all of them were in
session and so in some ways to me this
is all just testing right this is to see
what the response is that's why I made
the comparison to the casinos right to a
certain level like when you do that kind
of thing and especially if you do it to
two major different Casino Brands you're
ultimately trying to see which one will
give you money and which one won't you
want to know what their response is they
want you want to know what their
security protocol is uh and you know
effectively obviously in this case no
one's heard everything's fine but on the
other hand there is now an obvious way
to get you know state capitals to close
down as fast as possible well think
about like it's like an election period
and somebody just calls in or does
something like this at like a voting at
like some place where people vote yeah
at a polling center right so there's a
lot of ways where you can just merely
disrupt something at a time when there's
a finite amount of not to to throw too
much shade on him but you know if jbal
Jamal Bowman could just pull the fire
alarm this is effectively what anyone
could do to stop a vote that they don't
like in one of the states um I can't
remember which one on top of my head uh
there the their Supreme Court the state
supreme court was in session so
theoretically if you didn't want
business to take place you don't even
need to be in this country to be able to
say I don't I'm going to disrupt the day
how is Bowman not in jail well you think
is he was a school principal and he
would never ever do now seriousness how
is it that this man committed a crime on
camera how is it that this man committed
a crime everybody saw on video commit
the crime he lied about committing the
crime and Republicans have done nothing
cuz technically it didn't really stop if
it technically I asked the one lawmaker
and he told me asked no no no I asked
one lawmaker why he didn't get arrested
and he told me pulling the firearm
illegal right yes but they said because
it didn't when he pulled fire alarm and
didn't happen when they technically was
Voting that have nothing to do with what
I said but that's what I'm saying that's
the only reason why they were able to
skip that that loophole that's what they
told that's right that's that's wrong so
pulling a fire alarm falsely anywhere is
illegal right I don't it doesn't matter
if you're in Congress or in a school
Jamal Bowman did it and lied about it
the only reason he's not in jail is
because there's I'm tell you the
information that he told me yeah right
but that that's that's like that makes
no sense that's like saying why didn't
the guy get arrested for stealing the
sandwich because it was Friday what the
the location of the capital has nothing
to do with whether or not illegal to
pull a fire alarm the issue is that
there are criminals occupying the
government and there are no there's no
good men or women willing to do their
jobs not a single Capital police officer
took it upon themselves to make an
arrest look if a capital police officer
has the ability to arrest someone for
walking you know entering the building
unlawfully like breaking security if a
cop has the ability to issue a citation
for driving of their own valtion if a
cop has the ability to arrest you
because they witnessed you obstructing a
roadway a capital police officer could
just walk up arrest Bowman and say we
saw you on camera do it there's no in
vation needed but there is not a single
good man in the capital police who will
actually criminally take it upon himself
to enforce the law yeah and George
Santos was the only one who introduced
um expulsion papers for for J what what
is this reality we live in
where it in order for a crime to be for
a law to be enforced you you require
some kind of act of Congress yo if a cop
Witnesses someone falsely pul a fire
alarm he will arrest that person no
question anywhere Jamal Bowman did it a
single Capital officer nowhere just said
I'm going to arrest the guy I haven't
looked at it in a couple weeks but he
did get some kind of plea deal where
he's on probation he has to court in
three months like there was something
that he got sight right right right Fair
Point Fair Point you got to slap on the
wrist then right but that was the thing
he pled to this plea it came out
whatever else he released a statement
being like I basically did nothing wrong
but of course I respect whatever and
then the evidence came out that it
wasn't just that he pulled the fire
alarm it was that he removed the sign
saying don't use this door or whatever
and then pulled the fire alive lied and
that was sort of where I wanted more fur
from the Republicans but again chuah and
again the Republican that introduced
them has now been expelled from Congress
it's kind of crazy it doesn't really
make
sense uh but again like at a certain
point there's the lack of follow through
like you're kind of alluding to this
with the Border stuff like the
Republicans need to see things through
to the end and I just don't know that
that's what they're going to do they
need to stop barking and start biting
yeah it's not now time is like game time
to start being like Trump like if you
really want to like back your action
you've been barking we had the most
embarrassing um Republican lead house
and Congress to have the least amount of
bills passed last year you know how much
times that going to be used against
Republican I mean used against
Republicans this year for the House
Seats but that's the only saying they
should have done more stuff cuz I don't
feel like they didn't pass a lot of
bills first of all all is that
necessarily awful like what I mean it
looks bad the the headlines looks bad
the headline looks bad but like in fact
do we want the government to just be
continuously passing tons and tons of
bills more than the year before like I
don't NE want the only Bill they passed
was like changing the post office name
and add adding a new Street that's what
I'm saying like they the least
productive Congress in the past couple
decades that's actually a good thing
right but I'm saying they can't say that
like we've done this we' done this we'
done this they can't point to the record
they did nothing we don't want we don't
want them to pass bills we want them to
pass like criminal referrals right but
I'm saying like you can't say like we
did this we passed the most baned
security bill ever we done this we
helped pass Ukraine Aid we helped pass
Israel Aid like you look at all the
Republicans they made all these videos
from like
Christmas they they passed it in the
house but they didn't it's not going to
go to the Senate stop taking U stop
taking credit for something that didn't
happen but the thing is like it's not
that I don't think I think they should
be productive I think there are certain
things that they should prioritize like
I said with the Border it seems like
they're using it to stop Democrats from
getting more funding out of the country
and also they know timately everything
will fail in the Senate I mean it's a
weirdly unproductive time because we're
sort of staring down the the barrel of
another presidential election
Republicans only have control of the
house by a very slim majority I mean
when what's his name uh uh Bill Johnson
the guy from Ohio who just announced
he's retiring in like three weeks when
he leaves there's only 219 Republicans
to 213 Democrats so there's a certain
level of like yes I would like them to
do more on the other hand I don't
actually believe this could be a highly
productive time don't make it seem like
it's semantics that you actually did
something when you actually did nothing
you know back up your claims you done
stuff we need the ones that are like
limited government look we did nothing
hooray exactly I'd rather be like he no
Aid bills how about that but I think
there will be Republicans that can like
look I successfully blocked the Ukraine
additional Ukraine that is doing
something by doing nothing you have done
something yeah it's I don't for nothing
I I don't I just don't want like the the
goal to be like Congress has to say we
passed more bills than last year because
problem is with the average American it
looks so bad if you're a political guy
like us like we're so into this stuff
like we we cheer the on but then you ask
like the regular Average Joe in America
they're going to be like we pay their
salary and they did nothing it's just
the semantics look bad maybe I don't
know if all Americans would feel that
way though I mean I think there is
enough distrust of government cuz like
we want to look back at Co when they
passed all kinds of things and said all
kinds of crazy stuff like I think there
are there is a growing distrust of the
federal government where people would
say like maybe we don't want a lot of
stuff but if you tell average American
like hey this was the least productive
Congress just leave it like that there's
where the maybe that's how you just have
to twist one word and then it changes
everything the only productivity rep
have the worst Communications criminal
referrals investigations and
subpoenas but where's it leading to well
they're not doing it won't matter
anyways it's we're coming up in a Time
eventually where nothing will matter
unless either party has a super majority
because everybody's voting on party
lines so often now anyways the
hyperpolarization in this country
there's there's a chart going viral on
Twitter showing political ideology by
profession and in the 10 years it's just
there's no middle anymore it's gone and
I've been saying this for all there's no
middle anymore doesn't matter your left
or your right and that j z is proving
this that's what I was saying earlier on
the show like gen Z is also drifting
apart from itself there is a
disappearing moderate class in this
country well remember the it's gone
already the data shows it's gone CRA but
remember the the voting statistics which
said like women said the biggest red
flag if the guy if the guy they might
date supports Trump or Republicans and
the men said like the biggest red flag
is if she's a communist yeah Hey listen
my biggest FL I'm on the dating app and
he says he's a liberal or he has he she
where what why you you know what I I
realized really funny is that you know
growing up the Trope was that men are
sex obsessed and the meme is you know
men only want one thing it's disgusting
and then you start to realize when you
watch comedy videos it's actually
totally the other way around guys are
object oriented and totally interested
in sports numbers they actually don't
talk all that much about women and women
talk about nothing but guys men have
like a lot of like unique hobbies that
end up binding them together with their
friends so I look at I look at these
comedy videos and uh so I follow a bunch
of comans on Instagram I get a ton of
comedy videos 90% of the of the clips
that come from a guy will be about an
issue some and like it'll just be it
could be about anything like you know
with uh with Dave Chappelle look at his
jokes he's joking about Madison
cauthorne uh handicap he's talking about
Andy Kaufman and Jim Carrey telling life
stories all of these female comedians
the joke is they're always just talking
about their vaginas and so I mean that's
a CR for the shock Factor but every
single female comedian I'm when I'm on
Instagram and I hit refresh and I'm
seeing all these comedians I if I if
it's a female comedian I know that if I
hit it she's going to be talking about
dating a guy I know if it's a guy it
could be anything and I the reason I
bring that up is because as we're
looking at the the bifurcation of
politics between men and women I believe
it's going to result in this country
moving conservative for the reason of
women are more subject oriented and more
time constrained on having a partner men
are not so if a guy says I don't like
commies he just won't date anybody but
around 30 to 35 when women start getting
you know the biological clock is
sticking and they want to have kids they
have to try start trying to find a guy
but if guys are skewing to the right
those women will have to adapt
themselves to the guy not the other way
around yeah okay so you ever heard of
the book uh Men Are from Mars Women Are
from Venus so my one of my favorite
points in that book was the the
psychologist John Gray points out that
when men go to to lunch they're
typically going to talk about a specific
problem they're like we have a there
there is a purpose to it right they're
they're meeting it's something there's
something you do women go and they just
sort of gather a lot of information
right it's one of the reasons like the
stereotypic because like girls can be on
the phone with their friends for hours
and hours because they're wired to do
different things and I think both are
valuable but they play out very
differently in society like well look at
a family guy is the joke where Peter
Griffin gets injected with the gay gene
as part of a clinical trial and then he
calls I think he calls Quagmire M and
he's like hey Glenn and Glenn's like
yeah what you doing what do you mean you
called me and that just shows you like
the joke of the difference between the
feminine approach to calling someone
versus the guy it's like you called me
what do you want yeah but it's it's just
totally different and I think that you
know these things could be good the
problem is that feminism has really made
it so that women are trying to compete
with men in male spheres they don't just
do things that are natural to women and
like them uh it sort of makes it so like
the best female comedians that I know
actually have some really interesting
social observations right like when Ali
Wong who does talk about her vagina a
lot would talk about trying to trap her
Harvard educated hus or Harvard business
business school husband it was really
funny right because the way women talk
about like the way they approach dating
when it's not necessarily about their
sexual approach to dating can be really
nuanced can be really interesting
because it gives you an insight into
something you may not know it's the same
thing I don't watch female comedians
anymore I don't know why because dude I
she's going to be talking about she
dated and I'm just like all right that's
that's look you can ask a random girl on
the street and she'll tell you the same
thing that comedian just had but it's
totally it's totally fine if this is
what women find funny hearing another
woman talk about her boyfriend for me
I'm like you know that's why we we were
talking to the members only show about
this one female comedian who made a joke
about homelessness and I'm like that was
a really really good joke and uh but
it's just like yeah we talked about this
but I I swear I'm on Instagram and I'm
going through it and I'll hit a guy's
jokeing he'll be like you know so my car
broke down or something like that and
you're like oh wow what happened to your
car and or I'll be telling a story like
I was going to the supermarket and this
guy was trying to buy this Coca-Cola
right and I'm like oh what's this story
about buying a Coca-Cola something that
happened and then I clicked the woman
and she's like so my boyfriend here's
the trick my boyfriend I'm like okay
well I don't just unrelatable to me and
that's fine you're allowed to like these
things but anyway aside from all of that
no more winging about female comedians
the point is what I what I what I've
started to see with these social
trends uh uh when we've learn we've
learned this from Instagram women care
substantially more about social uh uh uh
how you fit in socially than men do I
think we've known this for a long time
what this means is a guy will be 35
sitting there like yeah you know what I
I want to vote for Trump these women
don't like it whatever I guess and these
women are are going to be going I'm 35
and I need to find a husband but all of
these guys are into Trump what do I do
yeah but then when you find all these
guys that you know they vote for Trump
and then they find a girl that votes for
Trump they're scared shitless what to do
next I I think that's somewhat true I
don't agree with that I'm speaking from
experience right that that sounds like
not that sounds like an anecdotal thing
not a data thing I'm to say like no I'm
just trying to say like a alpha and
Alpha together I think it's that men
will attack more conservative there will
be more men who are
openly outspoken about what they believe
but because women are socially observant
and that's what they're doing there will
be generations of women after that who
move more conservative to keep up right
because ultim what I'm saying is the
pressure is on women not men so you're
going to have women who are not Alphas
they're going to be saying something
like guy I will say whatever you want me
to say please I don't have a lot of time
and there's going to be a guy like bro
to set for Less what she believes in she
doesn't believe I'm saying she probably
doesn't believe in anything she's
influenced by social media to a great
degree to just say Joe Biden because
that's what all the people on social
media are saying but then when it
actually comes down to it she's going to
say I don't care I want to have a family
I think it really depends on her social
exposure right because if she's largely
socializing with women like maybe she
does want to marry a man but ultimately
she works in a female dominated industry
she hangs out with all of her female
friends and all of her female friends
naturally tack left they're all voting
Democrat she is likely to hold on to Bel
but as soon as you put women into more
balanced or uh social environments where
there are more men I think that changes
really quickly and it don't necessarily
think it's because of dating I think
it's because of social compliance Which
is higher among women but there's a lot
of liberal women that they're like in
their late 30s early 40s and they're out
there bragging about like being a
feminist and being a Li and like they're
single and they have a cat and they
don't have kids and I'm like and that's
why is your greatest accomplishment that
you don't have kids so that's breaking
down now because you've got these
articles say Business Insider where this
woman says I was lied to by feminism and
she said she wants to go back to all her
feminist College profess and says when
was this supposed to happen you lied to
me because now she's realizing none of
it made her happy at all and it was a
trick yeah let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.net
to the Iowa caucus event that's right on
the 15th of this month when the Iowa
caucus happens we will have a live show
and you can be sitting in those chairs
and we'll probably even throw some
questions to the audience that is the
plan uh we'll see how it plays out but
the only way to buy tickets is to be a
member and the link is available on the
front page of
timcast.net
user main says Hi join the Discord yes
we have a Discord server if you go to
timcast.net kindly guided me through how
to use it was that fun I remember
because we were you were on our show
that one time and they were like we're
gonna get you to do it and sometime
you're like I don't know if I want to
sign up for all this yeah I joined
Discord got immediately overwhelmed by
the interface backed right technology no
thank you but Raymond g sty Junior was
like hey I'll explain to you what to do
all right RJ McDougal says Tim how can I
work for your new skat Park I ran one
that hosted many comps jams and events I
can be a helpful addition who can I
reach out to it is a private park and
there will not be skate park people
working there because there's not going
to be anybody showing up to like come in
and check in this going to be a I say
semi-private because we will invite some
people sometimes that just basically
means it's private but we're going to do
a bunch of really cool stuff um we are
planning a party for the official
completion of the skate park the good
news is the structure of the new studio
it's done the rooms are done the green
room is done the kitchen is there the
bathrooms are all there we are really
excited and it may be mid-February when
we are officially inside so the new
timcast irall studio is being built in 2
weeks and uh I don't know how long it'll
take but I can't imagine it'll take that
long it could be a couple days and if
that's the case February 1st we might be
in the brand new studio it's a much
bigger room it'll be really really cool
really fun and we're adding a bunch of
new new cool crazy features one of the
features we're adding is called a delay
button do you guys know what a delay
button
does so let's just say for instance
we're talking about Epstein and someone
on the show just can't hold it in any
longer and they scream the top of their
lungs how much they want to commit an
act of violence when that happens we
press the button that portion drops and
it never goes live you see all big
networks already have that they do
really yeah every network has that so if
if you're watching cable sometimes
they'll be doing a live interview and
they'll be like joining us live to talk
about this issue is John Smith and then
they'll be talking and then all of a
sudden it'll just jump to the host being
like sorry about that everybody but
moving on and you're like wait what just
happened or they'll say like the call
dropped right no they'll they'll
actually I mean like those
connection dropped no they don't no when
they hit no I'm saying they Ed that as
an excuse no they will actually just say
we had to release the guest because of
the language they use we apologize to
people who are listening they actually
admit it wow shocking yeah when the
calls drop the calls drop sometimes the
calls drop and we roll our eyes like I
can't remember it was like U um I think
it was what's his face Cuomo has that
famous viral video where he's talking to
someone they start bringing up some
sensitive issue and then all a sudden it
does the he's like oh jeez and that
looked really fake but no no
my my point is quite literally networks
all have have these these delay buttons
and then they'll say sorry about that
everybody it'll just midc conversation
then it'll just jump to the host going
sorry about that everybody that language
is not acceptable on this network moving
on to the next story is the new studio
going to have money guns that shoot at
us Super Chat no only the if you're
going to have money gun you have to have
Neon Lights we do have Neon
Lights a smoke machine a smoke machine
the next thing we're adding is a
stripper pull that is not happening can
we make a raid like we will charge far
more for that far more hey you guys
should release your
calendar do not do not invoke that right
now okay somebody please tell me about
this calendar cuz how you know I do
not here to my brains out just fired all
right all right we're going to keep
going I am just sick okay all right
let's read some more all right Hans
grber says the missing name is Joe Biden
yeah yeah yeah everybody wants say Joe
Biden but it's just not the missing name
Ethan Helm says have you seen VI's uh
review on NBC review interview on NBC
news as well as his response to
condemning white supremacy strong start
to 2024 he's looking better by the day
the vras Swami was asked to condemn
white supremacy and he gave this
excellent response about I'm not going
to bend the knee to your religion I
condemn all forms of racial
discrimination but what you're asking is
you know he basically says you're
playing a game of trying to this got you
game I'm not going to play I'm not going
to bend the KN to your religion I'm not
asking you to bend the knee to mine but
I know you're going to run this anyway
we know exactly what you're going to say
you're going to say a refuses to condemn
white supremacy despite the fact I will
tell you again I condemn all forms of
racial discrimination and then of course
what did the Washington Post writer do
tweeted out when asked ve ramaswami
refused to condemn white supremacy
because these people are well look it's
not her fault she's developmentally
disabled it is her fault she's evil and
it's her fault that she's racist she's
asking the minority candidate to condemn
white supremacy like that's a bad look
team I know it's white lady doing it too
yeah all right Mr nickers gaming says
finally joined the members Discord last
last night I'm upset that I didn't join
it sooner it was a blast and stayed up
way too late I'm currently running on
three hour sleep 3 hours of sleep in the
past 48 Hours you see this is the
challenge that's a story of my life when
you when you sign up at
timcast.net to go anytime well we're not
a cult it's just that's not true I get
in the Discord sometimes and I argue
with people and I just leave I just I
just boo I'm a phantom I'm out of there
you're here for like one really wrong
and then I'm just gone you have like one
Zinger come back and then you're out
gone you're ghosting huh yeah they're
gone
ghosting so we have a whole bunch of
super chats of people giving potential
names but uh you know Sheldon Adon is a
name Alejandro mayorca 17 letters 17 is
not what we said Jessica messaged me
Stephen Kaufman but one and I guess it's
on Twitter Christopher Ray he was acting
Chief counsel for the US Department of
homeless security but there was two
different spellings of it one with two
ends and one with out so I don't really
know what you you can't just name a
person you don't like who's got 15
letters in their name okay yes you can
you absolutely can yes you can that is
your right can somebody please make this
into a whle game yes yes what what's his
name from the National Security um
Sullivan Jake Sullivan yeah is I don't
think that's 15 letters that's what I'm
trying to think in my head make it a
Wordle game with the court and the court
and it's like we figure it out you have
to you the name is really the letter you
have to let us this is a female guys
agreed to make this
fun all right Thomas Wright says what
happened to yesterday's show why isn't
it at least on Rumble and it's
fascinating because he said this at 826
and it is on Rumble uh the show from
last night is in full on Rumble check
again and uh it's also on all podcast
platforms I tweeted this out as well but
I will tell you the challenge my friends
um you know a lot of people will say
like I'll say something and they'll say
Tim said that yesterday but but the
people who say that don't realize the
average person doesn't watch every
single show and every single clip and
most people this is the funny thing I'll
tweet out we released a song I I tweeted
this out like the other day like our our
fourth song to hit billboard and they
went I didn't know you made music and
I'm like it's kind of wild that we had
four out of five songs chart on
Billboard which is like most bands don't
even get one song on Billboard charts
big names do big names do and then
they're like I didn't even know you did
that and I'm like every week we we do a
release we like do this long promo and
there are people who had no idea we made
music so how about that so uh when The
Show Goes Down And I tweet out three
times the show will be free and
available on all podcast platforms find
it here when we say like we're going to
put it up on Rumble and all these things
people still go where's the show and
what happened because there's no way for
us to inform everyone all at the same
moment it's not not possible it's why
people get mad when you have to
constantly tell people to When you
mention like subscribe all these things
because they have to hear it multiple
times because not everybody's paying
attention exactly at that moment other
people are doing other things so you
have to constantly use petition to
really get it across yeah and it still
doesn't connect not always what a guy
says chat GPT says Elizabeth Warren she
certainly has the power to stall a foil
n and six I want to know who the other
prince was like that one just was so
Random as long as it's not the artist
for Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren is 15
letters yeah but I don't see a reason
why she would be on the list I think it
has to be like probably going to be a
dude we got to cross with people that
were like known to have an affiliation
right step BM says they mentioned
redacting because of security risks in
home country of people which is why some
people think the prince is from sa said
Arabia these drops are not legally
damning they are culturally and morally
damning that is correct absolutely and
it may be a prince the other prince the
other prince that's so so intriguing to
me also prince Andrew must be livid
right now that everyone was willing to
name him but they're not willing to name
the other one well you got to blame your
mommy for like dropping you out of the
whole royal family for able to open that
kind of
warms let's grab some more Super chats
there's a whole lot of names here we go
what do we have here uh more names more
names more names another name I think we
got like 15 super chats saying
Christopher Ray okay there a lot of them
like 15 right Samuel Brooker says What
If instead of a famous person is an
unknown person whose very existence is
evidence of something much worse than
all of the grape Fair Point it might be
a name that as soon as people figure out
a name you've never heard of and you
look at you say who's that and you
Google search you go oh my stars and
gers the missing link yeah yeah MH
perhaps it could be anything perhaps
indeed oh another person said
Christopher Ray yeah again like 15 of
those all right B VIP says Alan dtz
claimed the allegations of a teenager
being forced into sex with them was
categorically false I he this phrase a
lot is this a diversion or H uh yeah I
don't believe dtz you know he denied it
it is what it is I don't believe
him I I don't know I don't know how
you're the lawyer of this guy not aware
of what's going on you know what I mean
like there there there are a lot of
lawyers out there they know their
clients are guilty but they're going to
provide the best events they can they're
going to be like yes but so you did
punch that man but how did they find out
you did the video they got was taken
from your camera without a warrant
that's fruit from the poison tree and
we're going to get that thrown out and
the case will be dismissed but everybody
knows you did it I pretty sure dtz was
aware of what was going on in my
opinion all right it was a different
time cam Pete says just like to say I
was the first in with Ray
congratulations Camp Pete the name I
don't you know I don't know we don't
know who it is we don't know who it is
Richard Klein says it's safe to to
assume it's not a conservative that's
rejected it could be a foreign leader of
a state that's being protected yep
exactly do you think we'll ever find out
who it is no yes well I mean not right
now maybe like another two years years
uh but what I should say is I believe
there is a possibility we we get the
Epstein list it just means we have to
win the culture war is that our October
surprise the October surprise is someone
coming out and claiming Donald Trump did
the whole thing and it's they create an
org chart with Trump above Epstein but
that's for the Democrats but uh you know
if Trump wins I do think there's a
possibility that that information comes
out so if you want to know who's on that
list look what did we learn from the
first release Donald Trump was not there
he had not met these women he wasn't
around he didn't sleep with any of these
women it's it's it's it's very strong
evidence for Trump that he was involved
in any of this stuff it's good
considering he was in the proximity of
these people on the left is trying to
claim he was involved by showing videos
of him like at a party with Epstein and
I'm like yeah Epstein went to parties
Epstein famously moved in Elite Social
Circles yeah and it doesn't mean every
single person involved did something
wrong fair point I just don't trust Bill
Clinton you know what I mean like sorry
he likes him Young
how young is too
young that's the question Epstein young
is too young no I meant Bill Clinton
it's kind of creepy when Epstein is
known for doing what he does and then he
says the word young because you assume
it means younger than he's already
involved in I know tering
disgusting there are demons out there
man there are
demons blue degolier says it's a Saudi
Prince remember there was a redacted
name because of being from a
conservative country okay but we have to
remember there's the redacted name
there's some other names and then it
says the other Prince so which is not
the right name it can't be the they're
separate things like someone on there
was guessing like oh this prince's name
fits the number the number of syllables
but they are two separate mysterious
people and S Prince has like five names
so they would have to put his whole name
out there I mean but theoretically
that's a transcript so they wouldn't say
like all of the names they might just
refer it by like the they'll name like
Prince or they'll probably put his NBS
whatever who knows that's probably like
over like 25 letters Dark World says
have your children skip a meal or two or
have your grandchildren not eat for a
week pick your poison I'm not condemning
people who do a deal with the devil to
save their kids I'm making the point
that when the devil offers you the deal
it's not going to be for a luxury car
it's going to be to feed your children
it will be the hardest decision you have
to make and I think it's fair to say
perhaps the majority of men would sell
their soul to the devil knowing they
would condemn themselves for eternity if
it meant their kids got to eat that's
that's not a I'm neither condemning nor
condoning I'm pointing it out if that's
who you are and you take issue with that
statement perhaps you should reflect on
your morals because some people might
actually suggest it is Noble to
sacrifice your Eternal Soul to save your
children I don't think working in
service of the devil figuratively or
literally is a good thing and I think it
condemns your children but sure when you
say have your kids skip a meal or have
your grandchildren not eat for a week
you pick your your poison yeah you got
to understand what we're talking about
is exponential returns if today you sell
out your country
so your kids can have a full belly
tomorrow it means your grandkids will
not have anything it means your
grandkids will live in the pot and eat
the bugs but if that's worth selling
your soul to the devil okay I mean think
about it the idea would be that you are
offered the the fian deal or the deal
with the devil we will keep your
children fed but serve evil you say
sounds good to me it's better than my
child starving what you're actually
doing is making sure that your child
grows up in Despair and desolation and
your grandkids are slaves living in pods
and eating bugs or your kids can go
hungry today and you can fight the
hardest fight you've ever fought and
then maybe in 50 years your
grandchildren will live in prosperity
and thank you for your sacrifice a
society grows great when men plant trees
whose shade they know they will never
sleep beneath so you know it's whatever
not condemning or
condoning what do we got here neglectful
sausage says Native Americans wanting to
stop Mass migration to their territory
was racist they should have welcomed the
zenos bulldozing their culture no no no
hold on there a minute I think we've
solved the entire thing there sir all of
these non-citizens who are coming in we
just place them on on the Native
American reservations and uh there we go
the Native Americans will be glad to see
M the migration culturally enriching
their reservations the left will agree
that it's not colonization migration is
a net benefit for everybody and these
migrants who are coming in will require
goods and services so what will happen
is businesses will start popping up on
the reservations the casin
some of these reservations have will
flourish and for those that don't you'll
see Walmarts popping up in no time
because obviously these migrants want
jobs and also want to buy products it
will boost the economy and in fact many
of these deeply impoverished
reservations could use an influx of a
new population I think everyone's going
to recognize it's a win-win right right
how many people are saying mer Garland a
lot of people are saying mer Garland
okay but I mean just because you don't
like a guy doesn't mean his name fits I
don't think the name's fit no because
everybody's like because of Ray and I
can't see from far just it's hard to
know mhm what do we got Hammer 111 says
unfortunately if Trump gets into office
he is going to have to round up all the
illegal immigrants and it's going to
look like the Nazis hunting Jews in the
1940s it's exactly what I said I think
two days ago on this
show and I think many other people have
alluded to already dreams of a strange
man says Did anyone say Mark Zuckerberg
with the space between his names that's
15 excuse me not National Security
related but I don't know I mean wealth
related yeah I have this whole thing
where like I think mocker Zuckerberg is
slightly younger than most of the people
who are coming up like you have to
remember there was a chance that he we
know that he's big and powerful now but
when this was all happening was he the
person of influence that would have been
courted by someone by Epstein and this
was 2011 right so Facebook was like
already no those documents are 2016 oh
2016 okay is today oh the email was 2011
but the but the but the the release is
now right no confused with the email and
then that one the question is who's who
exists today to prevent their name from
being released cuz the documents were
released now yeah all right Josiah
everine says hey Tim I've been listening
for a couple years now huge fan listen
to your daily segments while working I'm
curious what do you mean when you say I
think something will happen this
Saturday thanks it's uh January 6th
Saturday is January the day that lives
in infamy that's what they say well we
got swatted on January 6 in 2022 I think
it was mhm oh yeah yeah so like it's
2024 maybe January 6 get a lot of snow
and everything's going to be that's
going happen it's going to rain yeah the
the I just checked they're saying the
high is going to be 53° and we're not
going to get snow we're going to get
rain supposed to get 10 Ines of snow not
anymore I I predicted this wait that's
so upsetting because we were we were we
were warned like a few months ago there
was going to be a snowstorm and then it
rained for for three days yeah and so
you know Allison really wants it to snow
so we can go snowboarding and stuff and
then we get this warning of a nor Easter
in 12 Ines of snow and then I said you
know what's going to happen it's going
to be a few days out and they're going
to say it's going to rain sure enough I
checked again it said a high of 53° and
Rain Tim's a witch he controls the
weather my in New York it says a mix of
snow rain is snow highs mid 30s lows
watching a potential win to
stor all right toram says men and women
are not equal men can make long-term
decisions beneficial to society women
cannot men will hold each other
accountable for wrongs women will give
each other attention and reasons for why
they were right when wrong exes feminism
and women's rights were wrong I
completely disagree with you sir I
appreciate the super chat but I can tell
you why you're wrong because there are
Law Enforcement Officers facilitating
The Invasion on the southern border with
smiles on their faces because they would
rather their kid eats today and the
United States burn and your families
burn and your culture and Community burn
these men don't care about what is wrong
they care about what protects their
family so long as those men exist you
can't tell me that men can make
long-term decisions beneficial to
society sure they can also make
decisions of personal benefit because
they care more about their kids than you
and what this feature has for their kids
I mean that's the grand mistake
short-term gains for long-term losses is
is what it is my kid will eat a
cheeseburger today but then we'll eat
the bugs and live in the Pod in 10 years
that's what they're building I think
there are all kinds of women that make
good choices for society too I they are
more social they're different but
generalizing them too much is a mistaken
yeah there are good women and they are
bad bad guys like how many male
feminists are out there you can't tell
me that men are capable of making these
decisions when half half of Millennials
are are like 45% of millennial men are
are identified as like male feminists or
whatever like these guys can't make good
decisions because even women call them
creepy like even Lial real number is
that a real number 45% I I I think going
back to that's disturbing going back to
the Border thing do you think the um the
whipping um story really like haunted
them and there's the reason why they're
not being agents like they used to be
the thing about that story so was when
there were uh migrant from patients 4%
wow who were gathering bridge and cross
and no one was actually whipped they
were just Sor I'm sorry we got a
correction we got a correction here um
52% of millennial men identify as male
feminists gross H and we wonder why the
birth rates are collapsing those border
agents did nothing wrong but they were
so reprimanded like if they did
something so highly I think yeah I mean
that was some one of the reasons that
Alejandro mayoras is uh being accused of
dereliction of Duty which is that he
went and told Congress yes that was
awful and they did these things and it
wasn't even true right he condemned his
own agents I think the fear is a big
part of it right there are people who
want to lose their jobs but also there
are people who just don't want to be
canceled for theoretically being an evil
law enforcement officer doing something
they shouldn't and when you know the
ultimate Authority is contradicting
itself that we have these border laws on
the books but that the federal
government is not going to back you up
if you are in your professional capacity
enforcing them then your hands are
really tied what are you supposed to be
doing those ages were like that's why I
say they didn't get paid for like 10 12
almost a year and maybe they should go
work for a state border agency at this
point Tom pant says sometimes the delay
button doesn't work as Shephard Smith
found out during a police chase several
years ago you guys remember that no yeah
I do the the guy died on live on Fox
News and he was like wasn't he like cut
it cut it oh something like that was
like too late yep that's why we need a
dump button everybody yeah that's what
it's called a dump button correct yeah
yeah cuz we we operate with like almost
no lag I think it's like we have a very
very minimal so short it's like 10
seconds 10 seconds at most 15 seconds
yeah which we just like this studio is
duct tape like it's good duct tape
literally but it's duct tape yeah
there's a lot of duct tape everywhere uh
the lights duct tape so we have a
professional studio production company
coming in in a few weeks for the new
studio and they're going to have like
professional lighting well technically
it's Gaff tape it's GA tape it's GA tape
we're not not heathens here I'm just
grateful that the the lights are white
and not yellow because the yellow ones
are in the middle right yeah but the
white one is on me so it's like the eyes
is they're both on you the Lev of warm
like for me the lights like I can't even
wear my glasses in here because I get my
pop culture studio is great lighting
well the pop culture Studio isn't it
like a bunch of different lights aimed
in different ways Yeah well yeah there's
uh like there's four to six different
Neons that are all pointed in different
directions to give different the uh
purple and green so this is the fourth
IRL Studio mhm the first Studio had a
few stand-up lights second IRL Studio
had a few standup lights the third IRL
Studio which was which is now the pop
culture CR Studio had like 12 lights in
a bunch of different random position
we've slowly removed them and and
streamlined it I'd like to get like uh
soft boxes up there at some point just
to have less stuff up there they look
good yeah just there's there's you're
moving around a lot of stuff and
depending on what time of day is and how
tired you are you bump into a lot of
lights what we did for this studio was
in the corner of the ceiling there's LED
bar that wrap around the entire room so
all light is balanced and then in the
middle is warmer lights they're more
yellow and then we control the amount of
warmth that we have in the center of the
room versus the white on the outside of
the room so everything is uniform and
there's no Shadows yeah that's
interesting yeah but the uh new studio
is going to likely have shadows are they
going to li bang it out all I wants to
like do it or they going to do it in
between your shows no we won't we won't
go there if they're under construction
Oh I thought they're doing it here sorry
no no it's a building yeah yeah totally
new place totally new building yeah
but uh yeah man we're really excited
that should be in a in a in a couple
weeks all right everybody if you uh what
do we got here let's uh let's grab one
more tnp podcast says hey Tim huge fan
been a fan since 2019 just want to know
oh want to know I have accumulated
11,000 followers on a different app
called meet me is there anything I can
do to help let me know I'm not sure what
that is but I appreciate the support uh
yeah and we're going to go to we're
going to go to the uh is that what isn't
that like hinch 11 followers 11,000
followers on like a dating app I don't
know
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net
because there's going to be a bunch of
people there at the caucuses so we're
going to have a rotating panel the
special guests hanging out with us
talking about what they think's going on
you can be there too and it will be uh
intimate we'll put it that way meaning
like small amount of tickets and uh you
know relatively private event but uh go
to
timcast.net inside your suitcase and go
back to Iowa because I just realized
there's a there was a town hall like uh
Haley and um the santis on CNN this
election is so boring debate the debate
right today so so on the 10th yeah CNN
is hosting a debate between Nikki Haley
and Ronda santis and we are going to
counter their programming with our own
town hall featuring Viv Ras Swami
they're saying Ronda s Nicki hay ask a
questions from Iowa voters and backtack
C Town Halls as the state Piva Iowa they
have something tonight they have it
right now this is how boring both of
these guys
are I remember like 2016 okay yeah right
uh so Han you anything El oh yeah well I
want to shout out uh if you follow
timcast news on X uh it's and and on
Instagram but on X we just reached
100,000 followers it's been a ton of
work from the team I really appreciate
it and it really is ultimately all of
you guys and your support so keep
following them there because you can see
all the work from cnr.com that's scanner
news uh again same cool team really
proud of what they're doing there's a
lot of fun stuff coming up this year and
it's going to be a very very busy news
year if you haven't already picked up on
that so we'd love to be a part of the
people that inform you uh yeah and if
you want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at H.B and I'm on X or Twitter
or whatever it's called at hcbo guys
thank you so much for everything and
Brett thanks for being here oh well
thank you so much yeah guys if you want
to follow me you can follow me on
Instagram and Twix Brett dvic on both of
those platforms and please go and check
out pop culture crisis we are live at 3M
Eastern every day during the week Monday
through Friday not just pop culture and
celebrities but we get into a lot of
things to do with social media trends
things to do with Instagram Tik Tok all
of these things gen Z Millennials all of
it it's a lot of fun come and check us
out I think you I think you guys will
enjoy it and uh please go follow their
show guys PCC is great uh I'd love to
see you guys get over 100k that'd be
sweet is is is there a URL uh like like
the it's at like it's no like like
do.com YouTube no I don't think there's
like a URL for the show specifically but
you can find it also on
timcast.net just uh look it up on on
YouTube yeah uh that natural growth is
always good uh yeah guys um I'm
surge.com I hope you enjoyed today's
episode thank you for coming very much
appreciate it go to popculture
crisis.com perfect yeah you didn't know
that pop culture crisis.com redirected
to the YouTube channel oh okay yeah and
uh everyone should go and subscribe to
that bump them up to 100K 100K let's do
it y'all please all right we're going to
go to
timcast.net we'll see yall there
then